grand prix fit de jérusalem donc avec
cette finale femme qui va arriver dans
une petite minute et a donc voilà bah
écoute et installez vous ça va pas
évident après la journée d'hier de
commenter ça évidemment c'est pas c'est
pas le truc pour le moment le plus gai
on va on va quand même essayer de garder
les good vibes et d'espérer et d'espérer
et d'espérer et d'espérer un miracle un
les miracles arrivent ça commence à 14h
la partie les parties miracles arrivent
pourquoi pas aujourd'hui finalement on a
tellement pas eu de réussite j'ai envie
de dire depuis sur tous les matches
couperets depuis deux ans que bah écoute
on va espérer que qu'aujourd'hui diop la
réussite
enfin un acteur l'attendait affable qui
vient d'arriver salut fab auxquelles
tout le monde je vais te remettre à
temps je vais de mettre la caméra tac ça
c est ce que c'est fait est-ce que c'est
réussi
mais quid par exemple j'ai aussi cool
ouais bah écoute aujourd'hui j'espère
pas la dernière journée 1 mais c'est ça
peut être facile a commenté je pense
devrait pas durer longtemps vous écoute
j'espère que ça va pas être aussi
pénible que hier soir parce que c'était
vraiment pas pas quelque chose
d'agréable à suivre cette partie qui a
duré longtemps avec un scénario qui
semblait qui semblent être faits
d'avancé entre guillemets c'est dommage
en fait c'est 'qui bon show d'ouverture
pour le coup mais un putt mauvaise
gestion pratique avec une trop grosse
réflexion il s'est foutu ont hélas à la
pendule
c'est ce qu'il faut pas faire contre
niveau ouais puis même dans dans le
contenu ça n'a pas été extraordinaire ce
qu'il a fait maintenant sortie de
l'ouverture de coups après d'amd un
machin c'était vraiment moyen il fait
pas fou g5 qui fait cavalier à katyn
non mais il a fait une très mauvaise
partie hier oui bon après j'ai pas tout
suivi en détail mais disons après la
finale bon dépôt n'a pas cherché de
précis mais je
sur ferhi baisse quand vas tu peux jouer
très longtemps tu tournes avec ton
cavaliers étaient machin des blancs ou
jamais à moins de faire de forçat nul et
attend de la lettre à moins de deux
minutes à la pendule du conte sa joie
des trucs compliqués à ce moment-là
pousser ton qui ont de quoi were lagarde
machin ouais ouais je regarde la partie
2 en fait j'ai une question dans cette
partie un peu plus tôt on est en octobre
les deux je regardais du sud fait ouais
par là en fait ok bah ouais tact aura
huit bouffées puis très vite
ok mais pourquoi les blancs ils font pas
du g4 et charles howell vouloir échanger
absolument je rends dans ce dossier
contre je vois pas qu'on l'ait l'ars
agence en fait tu peux jamais de bach
était à tourteron tour de vis tu m'as tu
passes tes change en investit 7 est
heureux et je sais pas mais en fait il a
rentré en force là dedans actuellement
j'ai pas je regardais sans directeur et
j'ai pas vu depuis juste voilà position
sur l'échiquier bourrique c'était ça
après c'est pas une flèche non plus avec
les blancs quoi 25 50
je ne sais pas mais je veux moi c'est
juste que je sais des villes je pars
avec l'ordi en fait mais je me disais tu
fais j'ai quatre touches ton roi puis
voilà il a ajouté mme poudrette d'être
mal autant et puis oui mais bien sûr mal
autant d'alcool pendant une demi-heure
pour comprendre ça comme ça après la
même pourquoi pas prendre en réussissant
fait ce qu avec le pion à les nuls
théorique c'est sûr elle est un peu
chiante à défendre mais va agir c
mais du coup je pense que tu veux gagner
et prêchent sonore tournoi je crois que
c'est comme ça vaut le coup robot qui a
une histoire très probablement après la
position en soit je pense enfin je suis
sûr que quand il prend ici c'est nul
bâle a en fait plutôt tendu par ben que
non mais ça je suis sûr survie des
parties sur j'ai vu des partis même
magnus gagny finale comme ça je pense
rapide contre un mec forme et je suis
sûr que c'était nul mais c'est pénible
ski alpines ont passé mais c'est sûr que
c'est nul mais je pense qu'avant c'était
juste gauche concept de too short
message en avait joué une envie de ça
avec jude ailleurs contre jules une
finale comme ça j'ai réussi à défendre
pour la peine donc c'est défendable en
fait ce truc la mare
qu'ils soient pas rentrer dedans on va
voir mais aujourd'hui c'est clair que ça
va être ça va être compliqué salut grand
oeuf salut à bonn bird flu pius à lui à
la grandeur du coup de nouveaux tiédi
deux fois salut a tous p 29 à saluer de
rooney salue en manuel ménétrier savez
monsieur filoche mois de façon il ya le
tweak qui va partir à la fin de la
partie un poisson c'est décidé il y en a
marre donc le tweet partir à saluer
super génial fred power mais bon vous
êtes courageux de regarder aussi ce qui
à mon avis ça va être un peu pénible
comme comme journée salut à iode chaise
qu'il y en a marre way en a marre il y
en a marre pas surtout qu'il ya beaucoup
de live qui s'enchaînent déjà hier en
plus ont été moins nombreux donc même
pour nous c'est pareil quand même du
monde qui est venu mais tu as comme
c'était plus maxime qui joue et j'ai
aussi c'est un peu de mal à comprendre
je vois de suite sur les laïcs les
partager tout ça c'est si c'est des
événements qui aille mais c'est toujours
bizarre pour moi de comprendre ça c'est
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de gens en
fait qu'ils sont pas au courant du
règlement soit deux places en ce cas le
plus intéressant des deux joueurs que tu
soutiens que d'autres équipes qui
peuvent décider de rien d'autre qu'un
autre joueur qui doit décider de son
destin
oui oui oui alors je veux dire je sais
pas s'ils ont souvent fait dans les
conditions les matchs en même temps
imagine-t-elle dernière journée à l'euro
où la france doit espérer que
l'allemagne perde franç ais pas les gens
regardent moins denses et que tu vas
forcément regarder allemagne chip acquis
image de la france directement
même si ça t'intéresse quelques ben
ouais mais après après là quand même
avec une qu'une grosse qualif au bout
ouais non c'est vrai un peu moins de
monde moi je regarderai si je suis
supporters mais après c'est vrai oui moi
aussi en étant à fond contre contre
l'allemagne
ouais ouais bon après après faut aussi
pas oublié il ya un truc parce que mal
et du coup je galère un peu mais à ya
aussi noël qui approche à pas mal de
gens qui sont probablement aller faire
les courses et pour acheter les cadeaux
de noël etc
il ya aussi un beau ça que ce soit hier
ou aujourd'hui c'est le dernier week end
avant noël et à les gens qui quittent
prépare à manger ils vont ils vont faire
leurs courses niveau niveau bouffe aussi
donc pas y réussissent à sa tombe c'est
pas le sait pas le bon week end
j'ai envie non mais sûr de ça il ya du
coup maxime qui ne jouent pas
directement et et aussi le fait que le
ch le format soit pas si évident à
comprendre
en fait il est clarence site explique
bien mais là c'est pas toi le problème
c'est que non mais les points de bonus
au final c'est une bonne idée mais ça à
[ __ ] olefins sa [ __ ] la merde pour
les amateurs c'est y prennent trop
d'importance donc c'est une bonne idée
mais sûrement ils sont trop peut-être un
demi point de bonus où s'engagera dû
trouver un petit truc moi moins gros
mais en gros si jamais j'ai juste
expliquer ça comme ces jarres comme une
saison de formule 1 où chaque grand prix
bas c'est un grand prix et fait
classement général en fin de saison
déjà c'est plus compréhensible ouais
mais j'ai encore pour ça il faudrait
quand même que ce soit les mêmes joueurs
qui jouent tous les grands prix puisque
là encore les leurs différences a failli
à beaucoup de choses qui font que c'est
compliqué pour le grand public à
comprendre et voit la fin c'est normal
c'est tout à fait normal pas tué et nous
on suit pas un chant s'imagine en ligue
1 si on disait oui mais alors là je sais
pas à sainté en fait vous contre un
groupe de d'equipe de joue contre
d'autres et puis les points se gagnent
trois mauvaises passes
oui mais ce monsieur non mais je
comprends les gens du coup je dis plus
apte pas dans le sens où on y peut
quelque chose dans le sens où je
comprends les gens qui ont peu du mal à
suivre par contre les partis je suis en
train de voir que bien évidemment sur
une chaise comme on la récupère pas
parce que c'est quand même la dernière
ronde
enfin ses membres ont bougé le ps doit
tanger sur le chef bon
ouais ok donc il prend tous les risques
oui donc le kg 6 ouais ok demain pour
juste prix g10 et 2,4 c'est que s'ils
jouent la nage dorff bas il va y avoir
des variantes deux nuls forcé dans les
majors sont gratuits et devant d'une
force heures je peux pas t'en citer une
parce que j'ai pas à tes connaissances
mais bon de toute façon n'est pas la
mort elle se retourne au joueur fort ce
sujet un petit coubertin caychac solide
aura des choix et la betterave pareil
c'est pas une ouverture on va jouer pour
notre offre
il pense même pas non mais c'est un bon
choix de jeu la modern dance à moscou
donc j'ai six oued et quatre fous g7
cavalli ces trois des six aînés pour qui
cherche pas à jouer les ventes les plus
agressives à base de choux et trois
dames d2 g4 h4 machin ou f4 attaque
autrichienne qui fait jusqu à f3 je
voulais juste qu'on ce congé quand on
était gamins quoi normal un grand
classique
pour najwa ça des lilas et attend très
grande forme attention oui il joue à six
on voit où il veut en venir
ouh la la la la la la mais pour plus ils
y vont battre les saints qui touche tout
est faux de abc ce presque peu 6 oui et
non bah oui oui qui est dans le match
aller s'était faudra un visuel sur les
arbitres la voie qui lui fait quoi il
est il allé voir la joue plus vite du
tout libre aux bleus ce qui se passe
ce serait vous une qualification de
grâce et dégagent pas tu n'existes pas
prise de parts ou n'est pas en sueur
face à l'élite
c'est incroyable non du coût du coton
jeu le monde qui téléphone avec le avec
ont dit oui sans les parages les
parchemin interdit bas c'est ça et s'il
gagne cette vidéo de fou ça ferait pas
ça à faire le buzz quoi un joueur
utilise la méthode ruiz maximo candidats
grâce à la baie
ruiz pas du
ouais donc ont validé tout le monde la
connaît enfin c'est de faire cavalier
seul stratégie en touche de la justice
v6 trouver 7 et surtout parole qua non
surtout pas et stratégies d'antijeu si
les blues au centre ouest dans le cinq
des cinq des 5,5 bon mais faute souligné
que c'est jouable parce que lecavalier
dur et froid ouais guéant ce 3 et le
cahier le font à eux deux aussi qui
empêche le plan cavalia 2 kg 3e notre
mauvais mais pour nous il faut dépasser
dans l'ouverture ne connaît rien oui je
vous la méta druide ça tourne mal
au revoir mais l'espoir revient dans le
camp serait très vite je croyais pas du
tout dans la partie le dow se souvenir
très vite il se passer l'avons tout de
suite au discours une ruse dans le
meilleur set up possible boyard ok bon
un très mauvais évidemment ils jouent
aux échecs conventionnels croît rien
quoi est très très grosse erreur quand
même tu voir où cela va aller vers ces
bombes abc ça oui mais voilà il ya
danger si ce v6 keyyo c'est tout
candidat qui allie 17 aussi jouable pas
vrai tu peux tout près vous enfin tu
t'en fou quoi je te revois samoa logique
et d7000 n'y a pas de raison c'est juste
titre mais 21 virus c'est une blague
mais tu trouves tu trouve ça trop
conventionnel à fabas cabillaud sole
très bien joué accueil cette eau libre à
fouras d'exclamation en février il est
super fort que moi pas c'est incroyable
que je comprends pas comment il a pu en
sortir mais en de telles connaissances
on joue aussi bien aujourd'hui quoi mais
j'ai envie de dire des connaissances
encyclopédiques qu à paf bing chine
demande c'est quoi le principe de la
ruine
non mais quoi que ton adverse à face en
fait c'est à dire que tu t'en fiches
complètement tu fais ça et je suis quand
même avant la crise c'est très important
tubes et en tous lieux après bah tu vois
voir si on souhaite une europe pas
passer un très important face et mélo
stratégie gentil je sais que si les
blancs font des 5 tu joues avec le 5
voilà surtout bloquent le centre et vice
versa
donc l'anti jeu dans tous les cas après
sur un peu caché droite que farwell fui
3g hui trois sets tu te caches et si
nombreux tu tu pousses g5 un g6 c'est
bon t'as même le roi du rock et
éventuellement 30 à tout bien fait comme
ça il vaut mieux pas quand même pas
assez
c'est certes un peu trop conventionnel
femmes donc attention
bon voilà du coup d'un dépôt encore en
grande réflexion mais comment quoi faire
contre contre l'élite quoi mais là c'est
vraiment élitiste ce qui joue la croatie
a dit s'ils gagnent ça baigne avec une
ruine maxime vos candidats méthode ruiz
enfin les bills birdie au budget annuel
bord banon l'arvise se reprennent ce
soir sur internet quoi c'est normalement
c'est un peu au dessus tout c'est même
le soleil qui vient me gêner pour les
commentaires j'ai du mal à me placer
qu'enfin je sais plus quoi faire je suis
très mal
bon après le danger reste l'arbitrage
quoi tour un bond très conventionnel
grosse erreur voiture soit 1,6 soit b6
vous soyez 10 à 13 h 6 non d'abord je
sens que c'est bien comme coup c'est
c'est bien voulez quoi bah c'est
extraordinaire non mais tu la mettais à
bruxelles 17
c'était l'ouverture de le pays est juste
ou tempo quand il veut pas être mal
autant il fait suer dépôt ni face à
tours ne reconnaît le type de revenu à
bâle à l'été de la vidéo et il est déjà
trouvée oui tu vois je suis très content
quoi je vais je vais jouer au tennis
avec le prof tech prend de court de
tennis
quand ce matin ouais ouais voyez les
rafales de vent à 100 kilomètres donc
est basse et de l'ouragan va bien c'est
fabien qui est là pour le prof mais
écrit un sms débutant le court union
enfin si tu veux annulé il ya beaucoup
de vent quoi bon et je réponds je ne
suis pas pleutres je suis pas plus que
ça et je joue en levant est super fort
et
et en fait j'ai beaucoup mieux joué
quand il était très heureux il me dit
oui tu forces beaucoup plus sur ton
placement lorsqu'il ya beaucoup de vent
mais en fait d'habitude tu te places pas
trop bien parce que tu as un peu
fainéant et date obligé d'être très
ouvert
oui mais oui tu es très concentré et eu
très très bien du coup on a fait du
livre à fond quoi elle m'a dit oui que
du liffe la balle va tourner ce
fantastique fâche c'est et rafael nadal
sur le terrain comme un fou et en sueur
quoi l'europe nadal droitier non ouais
mais un moment donné il m'a dit oui tu
ton geste se ressemblent 3 celui de
rafah qu'enfin du coup il m'a expliqué
en fait je pense et c'est sa main qu'il
a montée en fait il me dit non ça va
tellement vite ça fait un genre de
sursaut de la soa mes nuits très
important de la faire remonter repasser
devant et repartir derrière
il m'a dit c'est un lasso mais très
intéressant ah je suis pas classico
l'école je suis complètement nul mais je
m'amuse
donc là haut tu sais où a dit ta vie est
un bloc d'argile ne laisse personne le
modeler à ta place
mais c'est vrai que c'est là où tu sais
où tu l'as tu as le tas le bloc d'argile
pas dégage tu veut modeler dégagent les
ordis 0,97 oui vous déjà dix ans à 0,52
à diminuer le meurtrier avait très
bientôt ils vont vraiment moins - 2 - 3
profondeur 60 moins 50 kw à lille à 0 2
déjà 99 % de chances au noir enfin c'est
je crois que c'est fini femmes après
c'est comme au foot comme dans tout s'il
arbitres demande la var qui veut revoir
enfin que tout d'un coup il te dit
non tu n'es pas leur faim j'ai pas leur
âge ou est ce à dire claude puel en
sueur cause de la défaite d'hier non non
plus j'ai pas aimé son analyse de match
les joueurs méritent un match est arrêté
rien du tout match minable en première
mi temps catastrophique 20 c'était
vraiment de la merde
non mais quand tu fais de la merde faut
le dire quand t'as pas de chance n'a pas
de chance mais même les mecs de winamax
temps sueur de déjà son discours d'avant
match contre paris te dise oui bon bah
si on prend 3 4 0 c'est pas si grave
c'est normal failli te dis bon bah tu
quand même à domicile et c'est normal de
prendre 4 0 enfin il est bien sûr c'est
pas normal mais mais en fait tu veux
qu'on brandisse paris sont pas dans le
même championnat que toi en fait non
mais les mecs de winamax se disent bafa
non mais je n'aime pas ce discours
plaudren c'est ce qui te dit il te
distincts disent tu y vas tu essayes de
perdre deux ou trois armes à feu at il
dit c'est la non mais tu vas pas mourir
en fait dans vivo tu perds tu perds ce
normal mais tu vas pas dire avant le
match ça c'est grotesque
bref et de deux meyer non mire c'est un
mal de temps mais le gars de winamax
disait ça énorme et même y te disais tu
veux pas tu peux pas dire ça être normal
de prendre qu'un butin il y aura encore
ici c'est normal de perdre mais pas
juste pas de trois buts et karkwa quand
même battu francs 4 0 à domicile c'est
jamais normal c'est bon de respecter les
plombs ça peut pas être normal by
adobuzz
on n'a pas pris cinq buts normalité
faillirent même france andorre je pense
qu'il ya plus de
des cars qu
entre sainte effacé professionnels vs
professionnelle et en dehors il fait ils
prennent pas tout le temps quatre buts
contre n'importe qui faillit prennent
souvent trois cas du têt ce ne peut pas
être normal de s'en prendre quatre comme
ça tu peux pas être mais c'est un
hommage de leurs comptes paris à
strasbourg c'était de la merde mais ça
fait longtemps que c'est vraiment de la
merde qui a aucun fond de jeu qu'on ne
vienne pas trois passes bon ça faut le
dire bah tu as le droit quand même de le
dire mais c'est la vérité en fait après
type un art à des excuses et à 50
blessés tu as la préparation qui était
mauvaise en début de saison enfin ok
mais explique moi ça en fait dis moi pas
ah ouais on méritait mieux non
clairement on est d'accord à 100% mais
c'est pour ça que tu l
il commence à me saouler enfin moi je
dis leur que c'est un discours de façade
etc ont privé les défenses murs à moi je
le dégager en fait qu elle fait bien
arrivé de chance
moi j'étais moi chez dégage et par le
coût en fait il a une carence diminuant
ainsi que lui prend la saison en cours
de route il a passé recrue il a rien
c'est pas l'équipe qui voulait
spécialement non mais non non mais je
comprends ça mais j'aime pas c'est fhr
saint-etienne c'est un grand club et tu
m'as de pamela vente un grand club avec
des joueurs
ouais mais regarde marseille ils sont
souvent très énervé même quand ils ont
eu des équipes un peu moins forte
enfin tout le monde était énervé tout le
temps oui mais tu dois enfin j'espère
car madame pitt mon nom et ma moi
d'ailleurs je vénère mieux c'est génial
mais c'est la tempe être fabien quoi sa
défaite 4 0 contre paris la tempête
fabien est arrivé c'est très énervé
c'était minable fait je m'en fous de
perdre un match mais jean il que les
joueurs jouent au foot il ya une 3
passes et pire tu perds tu perds mais là
c'était pour un mi-temps pas un tir
cadré et écoute l'interview
d'après-match m'vila oui on a très bien
démarré le match bien démarré du tout
ces thèmes ont bien démarré que vous
avez pas fait un tir cadré
bon là pas de joueur dont on se prend un
but où il va pas de chance enfin là
c'est sûr total déjà tu peux jamais
donné quand tu fais ça en revanche
marseille grosse saison a lâché par an
quand même gagné hier face et j'ai
regardé quand ils ont fait cette
victoire je pas d'affilée un petit nul
pleutre 1 1
et ça y est c'est déjà reparti voilà les
bon bah pas de chance ce jeu de titre
paris qui avait trop de vent j'ai joué
au titre du championnat avec leur banque
mais je veux enlever le titre les amis à
je pense que abc se jouer alors attends
je vais pas l'autoriser satgé plus de
coûts qu'ils soient de disques ayant
couvert y ait eu quoi la paix c'est
idiot à 4 b 6 oui bon dans mes voyages
outre un coup d'envoi le professionnel
non mais gérard c'est parfait a fait
refouler 7h si c'est ça c'est deux
prochains coups ça peut être tu peux les
prénoms est en cours rouge
non mais les noms sont bien bon après
douze ans que l'ouverture parfaitement
réussie par oui vas-y bouffe qui
s'apprend afin que je vois la ruse à ce
niveau bomba passe parce qu'il avait
quand même joué en finale du championnat
du monde à charles naveau l'avenir
allégeant les gens les gens de façon
décliné dans l'esprit des gens qui
veulent woodstock
je pense que c'est fini mais il perd
donc le nord mais en fait c'est réalisé
c'est une vraie mais et android réussi
pour la peine parce que les blancs les
camions avec 3,3 et le fonds a eu de
vraiment mal placé 1 tu veux quand même
faire ce plan là du coup avec h4 est pas
avoir ok tu fais plus au complot
non mais tu vas tu rêvais d'être bloqué
que les banques leur donne des deux
astres en h 6 6 a fait retour à des 1res
s'il s'appelait un coût intelligente à
jouer et oui votre cg 5 kg silice rock
et 5 de tous ses potes mais après rucks
et c'est plein de crème un faux-pas de
fer russes est bon alors il faut les
soldats ne doivent si ce nom il ya tout
mis en place la cia vu que les neuf
premiers coups parfaits clé nord ledit
projet la vendre et voilà c'est
compliqué quand même
coletto diffamatoires je suis très
heureux je n'ai pas vu venir en fait la
ruse bon je pense que je suis pas une
sicilienne jeu pas qu'une connerie même
et dodo dos au mur c'est normal de jouer
la meilleure ouverture facile mais avec
quand même le maquignon 1 mondiale
juniors on y connaît les les nouvelles
stratégies des choses comme ça quoi il
s'est renseigné
non mais c'est très normal en guinée pau
fait toujours cavalier f3 foods 2 sur la
pierre qui donc pas con quoi que tu
fasses avec les chercheurs
mais en fait il ya un truc capte pas
spécialement pas en fait en gros tu peux
tu peux revenir à zéro
juste pour dire de jouer aux quatre bons
j-6 il veut des quatre g7
en fait tu peux faire cailler 3 et 6 tu
jouais ce schéma parce que jardé six
feux de on se bat à 6 c'est grotesque
parce qu'il ya ces 4 celui-ci est
indienne ou tafer à 6 fin du coup tu
forces entre guillemets force aux cayes
et si ce que tu fais ton caisse les
trois tu joues ta pirc mais tu te
trompes à tout le système de moderne ou
wipo botha me compagnie du coup je sais
pas alain taton ses parcs et ses trois
oui c'est par du cash si c'est ouais
c'est une partie qui est parti pour
durer un fab 2 là où un gain hors très
rapide ont fait signer way ont roulé
noir il donc ce qu'on vise à niveau le
bloquer le sentier blanc pousse et sinon
tu veux faire j'ai 5 kg 6
je pense roth et daf h3 et qu'il va
réfléchir un peu je pense qu'il ya pas
réfléchir à cette question fabrice
hattry le plan nord me paraîtrait que
léa fazer l'aïe a même craint la part
ferme laissée se gagne tout seul en tuf
et g5 et
en fait le truc c'est que toutes les
poussées plus intéressant tellement tu
peux retenir à ses 5 tu vas faire plein
de choses
le roi devait de cinq points même temps
faire plein de trucs g5 l'egypte a battu
un petit coup droit ou cette dame g8
touret fuite
j'ai passé les pièces quoi il remet le
roi là bas je fais une réussite parce
que ma vraie rue je pense qu'il fait je
pense qu'ils font heureux cette dame
j'ai vite un moment donné oui je loue
une partie qu'ils ont montré web
informatique est vrai sur la torah y fit
chef ce poste c'est quand même fou 6 4 6
non non il faut qu'il prouve un point
claire ma part j'ai cinq fois par an ce
que tu peux faire
la droite fait n'importe quoi elle
courait depuis 3 j'ai eu trois spots
mais trucks camions faut quand même
prendre une décision avec les normes si
tu restes sans bouger et que les blancs
aussi il va rien se passer quoi trajet 5
mais si c'est ça c'est ça se joue avec
les mains assez calmes assez évident à
jouer là pour les voir c'est j'ai peur
que ce soit même trop facile si tu veux
bien fait j 5 et c'est bien qu ils
fuient suis tu veux plomb qu'on demande
c'est une filière non non il ya eu
c'était la défaite à da pour oui mais
oui quand même c'est n'importe quoi
alors comment il faisait nul c'est une
rep est possible ouais non je me suis
dit c'est ça
ok bon avec deux secondes sur la pendule
ans camille joue le coup suicide il
reste deux secondes 12 coups à jouer
enfin c'est complètement débile qua non
mais ça qui est énervant c'est que c'est
qu'hier ça finit sur un truc vraiment
bête quoi avez-vous le plus vraiment
trop gagner je peux pourquoi mais moi je
passe
parti vraiment beaucoup de temps mieux
s'oppose bien beau s'employer 2 0 mais
sur quoi les gens disent que c'est du
troll de oui et tout ça c'est juste un
très bon choix pour jouer pour gagner
il ya tout si l'on garde toutes les
pièces sur l'échiquier avec les noirs et
on accepte d'être peut-être un peu moins
bien mais le truc c'est qu'il ya pas eu
un seul échange donc pour rené peau
c'est pas confortable à jouer ce qui se
passe et qu il veut juste qu'on voit une
attaque sur le roi et peut vraiment
faire piéger six heureux cette dame
j'évite enfin même ça c'est possible il
tend maintenant mais l'euro enfin le
truc française sur quel geste heathrow
qu'elles sont non tu peux faire ça aussi
parce puis sérieux pas tous réputés elle
va jouer et f5 ce qui joue et on fout
bessette tu prends laisse pas ce qu'il
est advenu à m6 et tu ramènes vraiment
en masse quoi tu as juste tout envoyer
sur le roi blanc et si ça marche ça
marche ça marche pas ça par thomas mais
le truc c'est que bas avec les noirs au
lieu de avec les bleus en vue d'avoir un
truc que tu voudrais avoir c'est un pour
cent de chance deux qu'un 80% de chance
deux nuls et où je peux à 10% de chances
de gain pour cent de chances des fêtes
80% de chance deux nuls
voilà tu vas voir je sais pas moins 40
chance devenu le 35 victoires 25
défaites ou quelque chose comme ça et
avec les noirs bah du coup tu as ta
augmenter les chances de victoire mais
vu que la mer en vo faut partir du
principe que enfin ils sont tous de
perdre l'ouïe perdre 2 0 ou ennemis 05
c'est perdre c'est pareil oui c'est
comme un match de coupe où tout vous
êtes menés 1 0 sa 90e match quand on
vole bas tu prends un but en gros y'a 2
0 mardi mina est ce que est ce que ce
n'était pas du troll de faire monter le
goal hockey des cinq jeux par dépôt
d'accord vous êtes normalement si je la
mets des sig aussi à tous les ses
échanges a aussi ce peut être mais non
mais je pense que tu fais de l'antijeu
non autres se veut que tu fasses de
l'antijeu avait que 5
ouais je pense tu fais tu fais une
technique d'anti jeu ici je te fatigue
pas
bon peut-être
évidemment je veux faire f5 f4 fin de
façon qu'ils s'en fichent d'avoir un
truc non mais il va échanger avec 5 1 il
va pas se laisser pousser comme aux
estoniennes ils vont voter changera
alors la mégère dans tous les cas tu es
content avec les doigts ouais le stage
va se fixer quoi je veux dire ça après
peuvent lui avec g4 mais du coup tu
feras h5 et non non non non non non non
mais plutôt avec les franges et 4 je
sais pas stratégiquement cette fenêtre
ça un point où on en est on en a plus
rien à [ __ ] la stratégie comme une
sorte d'acte même tu peux aussi faire
rock d'abord pour le moment mais bon on
s'y prend tu prends ta [ __ ] et plus en
formation ruiz 1,2 tout à fait reprendre
un front deux projets c'est un peu tout
comme ça tu vas te faire ma vie avait
réussi soit des cinq mois je suis
heureux 5,1 g en taffetas peur de quoi
caillage de noix par exemple oui mais
c'est de l'eau je fais qu'aller g6 j'ai
rien à faire un chauffage 5 905 de ce
projet
ben non je te prends du roi j'ai par ok
banon met donc à 0.25
je te fais dames 18 ou le sommet où l'on
fait le plein faut faire baisser un
contigent ouvert je fais de l'antijeu de
partie puis jean le bouquet ces trois
jeux par ses quatre sacres un genre qui
vient
j'ai peur je fais de la ride à fond je
fais m6 ouais bon durban le choix je
sais pas maintenant je suis toujours en
fuite
je fais tous les coups quoi lasser
ce 4 ouais je te prends rien à faire
donne des 4 ouais c'est rien vous ces
huit gueddana 4 3 des 8 rien à faire je
comprends ces cas direct je fais tout
arrive ça y est je m'en fous totalement
sur 100 je suis roi des huit way to be
ce dont je suis un peu dans le dur mais
bon elle aurait fait que je m'organise
contre cette menace
tu as repris un coup je reprends un coup
aussi ce fait d'armes france d4
je suis un peu dans le dur là mais à un
couperet voilà beaucoup
non mais vous êtes j'aurais pu améliore
un petit peu avant non mais l'ours est
rien mais c'est chaud quand on se
regarde pas ça je sais pas sur quoi
revenus nous sommes navrés ceccacci
menace quoi brad front oui mais tu
prends et tu as quoi après bon je pousse
aussi s'est pas tu reprends je prends du
fou comme ça as tu veut se prendre au
jeu sous prendre la chose intéresse pas
en fait je suis pas du tout intéressé
par non mais c'est trop conventionnel
que je vais peut-être faire f 5 direct
quoi bon va prendre ouais je reprends on
va dire qu'on prend en b 5
ok voilà tu joue vraiment avec les noirs
contre le nouvel âge et je prends des
cinq commencé par me parlait poliment je
ne les soutiens on dit là bas navarraise
lars était très conventionnel terre que
tu t'intéresses à des pions de merde
l'attaquant la rue tu t'es fait ruiz
eefje quoi bon vous voyez qu'un métier
c'est rocky rambo ou ce jeune homme bien
et qu'on réussit avec mon cavalier ça
c'est horrible mais justement c'est pas
tu quoi il a il fait quoi là bas ils
commencent à réfléchir à d'autres partis
pour les 50 minutes dans la fiction
quotidienne ça
réparation a été très clair quand il a
mangé 200 g de haricots verts hier soir
poulet évidemment pas du poulet rôti
lien avec plein de gras dedans enfin non
il a mangé du frais poulet bouilli très
bien et voilà faire ce type est un
athlète et du coup ça c'était quoi
c'était e5 est usée carré des halles de
plug kg 6 pi g4 non mais bon on l'a
acheté fait h 5 gt donner un pion je
vois des vols d'automobiles je viens tu
t'es même pas obligé en fait peur c'est
vite j'ai tellement méprisé ton plan en
fait que non parce que je veux faire
c'est qu'à des fins qui j'ai trois ou
caliendo kg 3 a fait un truc comme ça
stabiliser et s'il se trouve que dans
mon pad attaques à l'endroit à sont là
avec l'élan de ce constat je donne tout
mais en fait j'avais peut-être faire
fouet 6 en réalité musicale et enfin
juste h5
ouais je sais pas j'ai du mal à croire
mais bon on peut être cinq mois de
voyage 4g trois voitures en dans tous
les pièges et ça c'est le piège aussi du
gars qui voit une caste faible 1,5 qui
rentre je suis donc non mais enfin tu
vois c'est juste pour expliquer un petit
peu aux gens en fait le niveau de new
beat ud2 fabre face est impressionnant
cavalier fille je me replace et
découlant de jeu de l'autre côté et a
rien de l'autre côté tu vas 5 fébé 50e'
joueurs et b4 b 5e phase 1 quand je
peins d'antijeu de porto gentil jeu de
par tout chef et l'anti jeu au centre
assez difficile pour toi là non mais
j'ai quand même un vrai bar mais fo fera
5 1 sur 5 sur le b 5
ouais temps évoquée ainsi qu'à foot ou
ses huit mois vous bouffez s'est vite et
là j'ai le plus envie qui traîne et
ouais de la tour alors il ya eu 5 jouer
cavalier le dos à la partie
vraiment la part de position officielles
ces treize que les jeux mais c'est là
c'est clair je dire le jeudi 6 4 ouais
mais j'ai quatre oui bon ouais je
reprends et choix cv web se fait recaler
g6 mais on en est loin de chez moi je
veux kg 2 qui est h 4e 3 déjà je les ai
quand même des vraies bonnes as face à
toi t'es nul moi je m'appelle denis
schmitt enough quoi tu vois je ça fait
peut-être rien mais ça fait peur bon je
veux partir je prends ouais ouais
heureusement les dom pas d'homme c3
bon ok donc qu'on prononce même pas
vraiment menaçants vrai nom mais pour
eux deux non mais c'est rien charmer les
bars je suis sûr mais les valway sait
plus si ce coup tout cas la partie c'est
bien que le vih 2 kg 6
pour l'instant on est prévu tout va se
passer
bon moi je te veux juger casting c'est
la vraie position sur l'échiquier c'est
celle là avant tout j'ai 4 ouais enfin
c'est quand tu aurait alors dix et +2
coiffe un oui mais on a bien compris on
fait quand on analyse est absolument
rien pour les blancs par les noirs mais
bon
encore in hand ou volley c'est en tout
cas une certitude
bon on né peut il se prend en faillite
continue de jouer vite car il est une
heure vingt à la pendule ouvriers et
leurs 23 mai il est pas là trot attelé
cher comme un fou et donc au sujet 4
l'autre option se faire qu'à liévin kg
troisième question d'être plus malin des
mois je sais pas quel point mais
pourquoi pas en tout cas on est dans le
dur mais on arrive à faire f 5 mm
et là ça ira si tata faire 5 sacks et
6,6 ou si fort à lui offrir le livre sur
la méthode horizons ouais bah oui oui tu
n'as pas bien représenter la méthode
bruit
un coot de toute façon ça peut enfin ça
peut être la dernière partie de la
saison et que je t'offre fenêtre avec
tous les james welch pc de l'ouvrir bush
costume au sujet du monde sur youtube
c'est donc des trucs
ouais les langes bien des gens de
partout mais le temps s'il vous plaît on
n'a pas de temps là les mecs enfin on a
on n'a pas les parties on n'a rien bon
bon bout de la main mais le droid jeu
quand je vous disais c'était 1h23 encore
pourri et 1h20 en gros pour nous après
le temps c'est pas non plus bas c'est de
l'argent qu'on rit mais oui oui même
bien sûr pour cette partie c'est être un
peu anecdotique pour le moins ça joue
assez vite je pense pas qu'il y ait de
gros jackpots honnêtement non mais hier
quand même ne pas prendre là nul avec
deux secondes sur la peau rendu dans une
partie super compliqué contre les pots
etc
c'est quand même un choix très étrange
non c'est inconscient entre mais prêts
donne au groupe allons vouloir s'y joue
sa chance à fond et lui pour le coup
j'ai faillit joue pour gagner le tournoi
il joue pour pour son petit fouet non
même vlm belge sera quand même favori là
il a eu son destin entre les mains à
plusieurs reprises tout de même un nom
mais c'est rageant de jouer aussi peu de
partout dans mes joueurs qu'après sur
les grands prix en fait en réalité si tu
réfléchis même là la place si la mairie
dont un dépôt oui du fougueux 4 il a
joué 4 6 2
même là la place il la mérite - ce n'est
pas dans le sens où dépôt il a elle a
fait une finale une victoire déjà et
maxime ilham et ils ont gagné autant de
matches dans les dents les dans les
grands prix sauf qu'un 1 qui a gagné un
premier et deuxième tours 1er 2e tour et
l'autre qui a fait faire défaite au
premier tour et du coup qui a gagné une
demi à une finale donc fondamentalement
clairement dépôt il mérite plus sur les
grands prix ça c'est sûr mais
quoi qu'il en soit mais ça on s'en fout
en fait ce que maxime sur l'ensemble de
la saison il merite plus donc après on
verra à la fin de la journée mais bilan
faim 2009
il ya des chances qu'on n'ait pas eu
plus de classement elo qui des fermières
parcours en grand prix à un moment en
fait le mérite c'est quoi hier juste
maxime devrait passer parce que tu
fasses on est au top 10 mondial depuis
mega longtemps et qu'on vive en
demi-finale et les grands prix quand
même coup les hoquets sur l'ensemble tu
dois passer un endroit mais mais en fait
on se force c'est un terme très bizarre
le mérite c'est donc fait un match tu
fais cinq barres transversales tu perds
ben oui tu mérites mais qui sans se
fasse venir sait pas alors je sais je
sais je sais ok je trouve pour le coup
c'est palm n'est pas mon problème c'est
geek show fut vraiment saison de merde
pour moi mais bon wen en guérit mais
bombe à outils a profité d'une faille
dans le règlement
cette histoire de vélo qui va très bien
et radjabov quand même gros traits fins
growth rig oui mais oui mais lui vaut le
seul à réussir le tournoi open est là
c'est comme mongo en faites pas je dis
que si fuller mais bon ben il a une
chance il l'a prise
clairement clairement non clairement
clairement clairement mais c'est vrai
que sur l'ensemble de la saison radjabov
et manga où ils sont tellement en
dessous de 2 ighirri aussi aguerri aussi
c'est juste que tu as trois gars et alex
enhco n'en parlons pas apte à quatre
gars qui sont vraiment sous de maxime
mais ils sont aussi en dessous de à
rognan par exemple qui serait pas
candidat dira la même mairie c'est un
bon joueur phare radjabov c'est c'est
l'ennui total dans tous les tons a kiffé
il en fait très peu il y à tout le monde
tout le temps qu'ils se préparent pas
qu'ils s'en fout non mais après il a sa
place tant mieux mais j'ai eu avec m
il est quand même intrinsèquement tu as
des joueurs moins forts que maxime n'est
pas je ne trouve pas intrinsèquement
vraiment moins fort que maxime non ce
qu'ils t'ont attitude un peu désinvolte
dans le chic et feu
toi vite ce machin mais bon en fait il
est quand même dur à jouer à paris pas
loin des 2 27 80 s'est longtemps
illustré et aussi sa prépa des fois je
trouve ça un peu bizarre quoi ce qui
fait la démo de répéter l anglaise alors
que contre belfort delle a souffert à
fond et un accent qui l'a pas révisé
hier
ouais c'est bizarre quand maxime de
rentrer dans le truc avec eux si ce
qu'il a joke on ne joue pas il dit juste
inconscient fait mais après en fait il
se trouve que ça montre aussi une grande
confiance en lui parce que il secte ait
préparé mais il va jouer des positions
qui lui corresponde oui c'est trop des
ressources mais jugent eux c'est martin
je trouve ça fou mais pour moi ça prouve
juste un truc tout ça ça prouve le truc
dont on parle avec toi depuis longtemps
c'est que ça devrait être un circuit à
l'année sur douze tournois où tu marques
des points et à la fin de la saison on
prend on prend les huit meilleurs ouais
c'est ça prouve qu'il n'ya pas ya pas
assez de tournois en réalité parce que
quand tu joues une place sur un sur un
high low semaine où tu joues de place à
une coupe du monde
au final c'est quand même pas la coupe
du monde est là et la semaine sur un
tournoi une ou deux places c'est quand
même un genre à une semi la tri mais
scinder millagou est là le jour j les
banlieues comme les grand prix c'était
moins une loterie parce que c'est sur
trois tournois et tu vois qu'au final
c'est gris tchouk m'amène et pottas tu
peux pas avoir de grosse surprise là bas
tu vois si le grand prix le grand prix
en bourse et sur un tournoi de plats
stade hudak et aux candidates parce que
je veux dire d'humeur d'un sur quatre
tournois il y va pas oui mais vers une
coupe du monde tu fais jouer la coupe du
monde quatre fois tu donnes des points à
chaque fois il ya les radjabov qui se
qualifie pas wang hao tu fais jouer live
man 4 fois et tu donnes des points et se
qualifie pas non plus non je te le dire
par là c'est comme si tu dis oui bon bah
on fait des grands prix de formule 1 a
en fait on voulait titre mondial sur le
grand prix du mexique mais c'est
vraiment le grand prix que tu dois
gagner lara à tuer tes meilleurs toute
la saison non at il est pas champion du
monde
je trouve ça quand même un petit peu
dommage je trouve ça un petit peu
dommage
non je dors système peut être clairement
améliorée et qu'est-ce que ça m'embête
que pour un tournoi aussi important que
les candidats on donne trois places sur
des sur des semis loterie je vais pas
dire des total notre hymne et sur des
semis l'entry ça m'embête un peu
quand même un petit peu non après la
world cup sera toujours était
qualificatif oui mais ça n'est pas pour
ça que c'est bien mais oui non et le
circuit de tournois je suis d'accord
mais alors du coup qui à droite je cite
on passe qu'est ce que tu fais des
tournois open est ce que c'est toi fermé
du cou excluent de facto non mais j'ai
su que rien du tout en fait je refais
tous déjà je ne fais je ne fais plus que
détourne à élimination directe ça me
saoule donc je fais un circuit de qualif
je fais un vrai truc en fait voilà deux
ans
mais qui est ce que tu as des mecs
qualifiés d'office pour le tournoi des
gens qui rentrent en coeur quand mon
huitième que j'en ai genre je prends je
prends si je prends je prends les seize
mieux classé sur sur les deux années
précédentes quoi je suis de moyenner
l'eau sur les deux années précédentes et
je prends les seize mieux classés c'est
entre caen et tutus qu'on sent qu'on 64e
32e
bah je sais pas je réfléchis avant
qualificatif
il faut que les mecs qui est dû ce
qualifier et pas un désavantage et c'est
bon alors là je le temps de se reposer
un bon voilà je prends 32 mais qu'au
final je donne 16 place d'office je fais
je fais je fais un tour mois pour
récupérer les 16 autres on m'a tant pis
là ce sera moins juste pour les places
17 32 mais on peut pas tout faire aux
échecs on part de loin et après je fais
le circuit avec 32 joueurs sur sur six
tournois quoi donc
mais je leur fais je fais les grandes
chaînes tour et ou quoi mais je fais un
peu tout les cadences ça par contre ça
m'embête pas un peu tout les cadences
pourquoi pas au final deux façons tout
se joue au rapido départage donc voilà
on va vraiment qu est le plus fort et
c'est dommage surtout que huit places
qualificatives aux soins oui oui
sur les 32 on a huit qui vont quoi mais
voilà ou quelque chose comme ça je sais
pas exactement j'ai pas vraiment
exactement réfléchi mais mais il
faudrait fort et que tous les tournois
compte ça c'est sûr mais quand on a
comme attendu vers cette partie ce que
ça donne
mais qu'ils avaient faim va pas bête et
se dirige vers g3 et le tronc avec 5 et
il espère que les normes vont prolonger
cas qu'on ne va pas le faire mais pour
faire un jeu prend est bien fixé les
cases blanches et qui est plus 2 et 5
chez noir d'accord je prends tu prend
effet h5 mais mon père de cinq enfants a
quand même
enfin radio l'avion prend h 55 kg 3
stratégiquement c'est quand même 4 5 et
les l'autre qui allait devenir blindés
ont le dos j'ai trois mois jamais été
qu'un jeu parfois fuite dont il a tenté
ça va mais c'est à essayer le même si tu
fais un jour f3 roy fr de west c'est
vrai qu'il ya rien non mais peu d'allant
à devoir être contraint de tenter un
truc comme ça ça sent pas bon de
personnes là pourquoi c'est la russie
qui a le monopole sur les candidats mais
papa une instance impériale qui injecte
de l'argent les échecs maaf l'add on a
parlé et les candidats ils ont eu lieu
en allemagne y avait un joueur qui
étaient vraiment très faibles qui avait
été mal card
c'est pas les russes qui ont qui ont le
monopole jugement qu'on dit que c'est
les russes car nos pôles sur les
candidats n'ont jusqu'alors votre
organisme et les candidats soient pas
tout autant aussi bas en 2013 c'est à
londres
ouais 2015 c'est en russie les 2017
c'était en allemagne non c'est pas en
allemagne 2017 l'allemagne n'existait si
c'était berlin si c'était en allemagne
donc en fait oui enfin ça peut être sait
pas toujours aussi quand il souffre des
fois envolés russe et son usage est le
fric dans les échecs mais c'est en
général les gens sont plein ou pas
d'ailleurs non les joueurs s'en
plaignent pas à londres kramnik wild
card par un anglais mais bon il a mérité
kramnik et on se régler dans la zone et
à qui on fait l'ordinateur fait ce qu'il
veut fassi veut pas un russe qui veut un
chilien est pendante chine et enfin à
condition qu'ils soient éligibles
kramnik en fait c'est un joueur qui
compte en attendant le bon c'est un
ancien champion du monde
non il n'a pas énormément
désenchantement
en activité qui ils se trouvent les 3
numéro trois mondiale à ce moment là
donc je n'apprends pas le champion du
monde de 75 ans qui alzheimer coincé tu
prends un vrai qu ils eurent trois
mondial à ce moment là et qui est
champion du monde pas quel titre c'est
quand même un scandale qua non mais en
plus ça en vrai si maxime y joue là il
of men à l'iccn qu il prend sûrement pas
la possibilité d'éligibilité à la wild
card et c'est sûrement lui qui l'a donc
au bout d'un moment faut arrêter aussi
enfin j'ai rien à un moment donné je
fais quand même des choix et ses choix
bah ils se payent le prix fort et c'est
vraiment pas de chance et tout ça mais
le choix de ne pas faire la teuf men et
privilégier la sinne que phil cup ou ou
graines que ou ou à nos tournois il a
quand même été pris après c'est pas une
critique un fire c'est dur de faire une
saison il ya peut-être des raisons qu'on
connaît pas et cetera on voit ça d'un
oeil extérieur mais géré à un moment
donné tu es pas venu pour le bloquer non
plus donc enfin ce qu'est ce que je veux
dire oui ils se changent et ou pas au
oui non mais c'est comme mary chain co
finit 5ème et la 3ème plus de problèmes
avec son cocon d'identité parce que ce
n'est pas le premier donc lg oui donc il
n'existe pas et demba l'egypte
donc à un moment donné
il ya aussi des choses c'est vraiment de
la malchance pas de réussite s'il ya
vraiment pas de réussite du tout pour ça
mais à un moment donné je remets dire tu
payes tu payes tes choix quoi et là il
est vrai esprit très parmi traîtresse
par le but ultime c'est de faire les
candidats faut tout mettre en oeuvre
pour à dire que là en faisant ce qui
s'est passé comme ça tu sais que tu as
quand même de grandes chances d'y aller
mais c'est pas 100% ratez jamais 100%
mais mes larmes en faillite qui le donne
un désavantage quand même secteur fatiha
certains tournois on a d'autres qui sont
gays vivre tu ne peux pas jouer
donc tu tu enlèves de facto des chances
après moi je serais quand même mon tweet
et tout pour essayer de secouer tout ce
que je suis je que je suis le premier à
vouloir etc
mais je veux dire qu'à un moment donné
là dessus quand même dire que alex haine
qu il va c'est pas juste de l'avocat il
est devenu éligible ce qui a light of
man et c'est le tournoi que joue pas
maxi non quelque part j'ai envie de dire
c'est le destin qui te rionnais quoi tu
en quelque sorte et wang hao qui est le
tournoi
linteau pas signé c'était juste un autre
tendance mais peut-être sur ya un autre
mec que mougins richard rapport plaide
alex n court et quand même pris la
wild-card en séparer film est malin mais
je veux dire que c'est le sait vraiment
le destin qui te rionnais bon après ça
se trouve radjabov roquefort faux
candidats max le remplace et grâce à
tout ça il ya l'excellent qu il ya moins
de gaouaoui les mecs comme ça confie max
marque 2 0 à chaque fois et il gagne les
candidats là dessus et le destin rigole
une fois de plus
en fait je dis on peut pas on n'est pas
devin sur l'avenir mais hicks qui est
certain c'est que la programmation
c'était pas une pro nation qui semble
donner à prêter au combien de loin moi
je non non ça c'est enfin je suis
d'accord avec toi très clairement les
candidats c'était quand même un des
objectifs principaux de la saison mais
c'était pas l'unique autre objectif
c'est ça et en fait en faisant ce
programme sont là normalement ça doit
passer
mais comme le dit titi qui tu enlèves
des chances
il se trouve que ben finalement c'était
pas passer pour l'instant à l'heure
actuelle ce que mes pots peut nous la
peau mais parce que radjabov peut encore
faire forfait des choses comme ça mais
ça sera ric rac
dans tous les cas quoiqu'il en soit la
poste grâce à des événements extérieurs
le truc le truc qui peut rassurer c'est
que pour être un peu positif c'est que
vlad pense vraiment qu radjabov qui va
faire forfait donc rentable parce que
vlad c'est souvent un hymne aux autres
et ça se vend à nostradamus mais vlady
pense que il pense qu'il va avoir le
forfait de rajab à un maçon là
franchement je vois pas où tout le monde
se répandent max s'il ya un forfait de
rajab avons vu ces radjabov qui a
éliminé max max fait 3ème de la coupe du
monde il ya une place de plus mais un
moment pour flatter qua non pour quoi il
ferait forfaits pass kader fellah finit
à - 5 - 6 kills un peu délaissé d'un
tête des intéressés par les échecs face
à elle c'est une intuition de blad le
le forfait de radjabov ya pas
spécialement d'un faux a lâché fab
normand rajotte a tout le temps dit que
c'est parce que j'avais joué c'est déjà
énorme et est là et bien de mieux aussi
pour des raisons médicales ce tournoi là
alors je sais pas à quel point c'est des
vrais raisons médicales ou quoi mais à
l'époque pour moi ils peuvent avoir
rarement des produits médicaux musicaux
pour moi de toute façon soit c'est un
vrai poème médicale et dans ces cas là
bas qu'ils se remettent et machin par
contre si c'est un truc inventé pour moi
il devrait être forfait d'office pour
tout le cycle et l'a mis là même preuve
oui mais je veux dire par là que
moralement si jamais c'est une fausse
preuve qu'il a fait et qu'est une
maladie pour moi mais tu vas japon et au
large et j'ai prouvé mais pour moi
moralement en fait c'est fin tu sais le
plus en fait non répond ah tu triches
lui fais un logiciel lancé
officiellement sa carrière pour moi mon
moralement si tu veux si tu as inventé
des fosses des fautes des fautes truc
médical médicaux c'est très grave s'il
ya des gens qui sont vraiment malades et
quelque part nous mais bon même partant
du principe qu'il a vraiment dit oui non
c'est une mais c'est mais c'est pour ça
on va partir du principe qu'il a un truc
c'est bien ce que je dis donc on va
partir du principe qu'il a vraiment
quelque chose qui esquisse qui est tout
à fait possible et du coup bah on lui
souhaite vraiment bon rétablissement
ça c'est clair mais ça va encore dans ce
sens là oui pour être à l'intuition de
vlad peut-être du coup si oui si je sais
pas ce que ça peut être n'importe quoi
stoner cyber c'est quelque chose de pas
grave pour la peine pas son nom mais
aussi le fait moi ce qui me fait dire
que c'est quelque chose de vrai pour la
peine c'est que ils n'ont pas communiqué
dessus
ah oui non mais tu vois aronian qui
s'organise le truc d'opération il vient
de faire sur twitter il vient comme
unité à fond machin parce que tu as le
mec se sent un peu mal de faire ça et
donc ils continuent munich à fond sur le
fait que oui je suis vraiment malade
pour moi le fait de pas du tout
communiquer ça va plutôt dans le sens
justement de quelqu'un qui est vraiment
malade parce que si tu as quelque chose
de grave ou quoi tu veux pas que les
gens le sachent ou pas grave d'ailleurs
mais suivant ce que tu attends tu vois
ce que je veux dire l'uic un peu de rage
et si je sors bien il faut f5 de joueurs
donc je pense vous a vraiment quelque
chose personnellement je pense pas du
tout que ce soit du feq
les kennedy l'azéri mais quand même ce
théâtre en gouvernant a poussé pour
qu'ils jouent ce qui est important pour
eux je pense benz et shaqiri l'abandon
du hockey mais les milliardaires
qu'est ce que t'en as faim mais lui il
personnellement il s'en fout sûrement
oui mais déjà en fait tu imagines tu es
milliardaire le gouvernement te pousse
ta macron qui tapait du oui enfin toi
t'es nul moi je m'appelle paul murphy
copain jean louis battu lille battu
muffins impose de oui-oui millions
d'euros je vais mais en fait là il se
trouve que moi j'avais déjà j'ai déjà
deux milliards donc en fait c'est moi
qui vais racheter ton pays en fait
d'ailleurs s'est fait très attention
c'est toi qui va les jouer les candidats
verts non non tu vois je pense pas que
qui que ce soit puisse lui mettre la
pression et je pense pas qu'on puisse
qu'on puisse l'acheter avec de l'argent
non non ma près du couvent st on espère
qu'ils laisseraient cool qu'une place se
libère d'une manière ou d'une autre
mais bon tout ça pour dire intuition de
vlad il y va pas
donc voilà du coup ce serait ce serait
la bonne nouvelle fait 5h 5 jouer on
verra
non mais bon il ya des bonnes intuitions
calamiteux dit navarra au septième coup
il connaît plus la prépa il te dit x10
ait eu 10 à bon port d'alger le droit
non c'est l'os et low cost un gain avec
g4 peut-être au prochain
non mais de façon oui il va peut-être va
la gagner mais donc enfin c'est loin
d'être fille est encore la wild card qui
peut-être changer d'avis il ya peut-être
radjabov qui n'ira pas en tout cas et
dans ses déclarations il a déjà dit en
plus mais où alors il sait qu'il a des
problèmes de santé depuis enfin on n'en
sait rien faire totalement de ces que
des cires ce que le fait qu'ils te
disent direct en interview après le
match je sais pas si j'irai va savoir
pippa ya un truc étrange là dedans fab a
énormément totalement heureux de jouer
les candidats que c'est bizarre de dire
mais bon tant les a déjà joués
ça s'est mal passé peut-être qu'il a pu
l'illusion juste du radio
bref du coup il ya une chance du coup il
a une chance à ben basât toujours des
gens déjà parti oui il peut le gagner et
il peut gagner après les départage et je
veux juste en deçà déjà sa première
chance la deuxième c'est que d'un
désistement tu es un changement d'avis
pour la wild card que tu excelles
concurrents puisque je savais toujours
des trucs en fait donc du tout qui
refusera pas aller jouer non tiens je
pense son idée sur g3 c'est juste 2 je
ne m'intéresse pas bouffe le cavalier
voix dire je peux même pas tu peux mais
d'autres y viennent pas de pire je
n'aime pas de chef est ce la vie oui
cela non
ouais mais après faut qu'ils partent de
toute façon voyage s'il veut les gagner
la foire passer par un truc comme ça non
quoi qu'il en soit un truc rucks on les
joue au risque et il a raison c'est
bienne prend sa chance n'a sur ce point
de vue là on peux pas le critiquer mais
alors pas du tout je sais pas je crois
qu'on en disait plus haut que c'était
pas sérieux pas les jouer les grandes
chaînes tourbe après ce qu'on disait
avec fable ça dépend ça dépend des
objectifs ça dépend de sa dépend de
plein de choses après c'est c'est des
choix qui sont qui sont faits et qui
voit là c'est pourquoi pas non non mais
qu'ont ils seraient probablement dû
passer par tout ça aurait dû passer quoi
quoi qu'il en soit mais magnus je pense
à saison quand il avait joué le match en
novembre la contrecarre ouanna il avait
il avait appel grande chasse tournellec
to the times magazine l'âge de choix le
monde sait qu'un truc tu sais quand même
différent c'est trop gros car on
enchaîne bus qui devait faire une
utilisation des trucs là caruana aussi
laver a fait des trucs mais oui oui la
merde j'avais zappé la cime que fils non
caruana
non je crois que les jeunes il avait
zappé quoi alors je sais qu'il avait
zappé un truc mais nous avons pu mais en
tout cas je sais que personne
signe que fil de ses voyages en rentant
la préparation est en gros tu vois ils
peuvent un peu à voir les wild cards où
il voulait mais il jette pas le circuit
principal toi je n'en restait pas là
londres en fin de saison
ouais voilà c'était ça il y avait
londres il y avait autre chose rennes
ans après c'est difficile et qu'est-ce
qu'ils étaient bien je suis en fait on
sait déjà deux ans steel storm je me
sers pas de tout ça on a présente que
genre compliqué en plus de l'extérieur
de savoir exactement les tenants et les
aboutissants après nous regarde avec un
oeil de supporters et c'est comme quand
tu regardes comme quand tu regardes
l'est c'est ce ré des choix qui sont
faits me réalité tu parles avec paulo
bre teneur après et puis tu vois que les
problèmes ils sont ailleurs tu regarde
d'un oeil extérieur façon tant que
supporters toi dans les échecs en
réalité quand les supporters extérieur
tu es forcément fab pour les tournois
qui ont de l'enjeu les grandes chaînes
sourds en réalité pour nous c'est de
l'exhibition chasser comme ça mais c'est
comme si tu as j'aime bien rogers est ce
que je préfère qui gagne le tournoi
d'exhibition au chili contre iref là
qu'ils ont joués ou est ce que je
préfère qu'ils aient gagné la finale de
wimbledon contre djoko en fait je
préfère tiennent la finale de wimbledon
contre djoko contre 100 en exhibition au
chili aurait des sanctions jugées même
pas regardé donc à c'est toujours pareil
aussi quand et le joueur je comprends tu
vas parler comme fait des queues
maximise aille jouer c'est tournoi là
parce que c'est ça doit être très
lucratif j'imagine mais je parle pour
fait déjà pour la peine mais en réalité
si quand tu regarde d'un oeil extérieur
tu vas tu préférais qu'il se repose
qu'ils soient fond où je sais pas tu dis
ça comme ça donc c'est c'est toujours
aussi difficile de
te parler de ça de supporters est ce
qu'un boguey mais j'aimerais bien que
l'om s'endettent à fond qu'ils achètent
ronaldo mais bon j'ai pas à la famille
dreyfus en sueur il faut laisser
milliardaire voiture a plus rien mais on
a gagné ligue des champions d'europe
mais c'est juste pas possible c'est
compréhensible aussi affable c'est
normal non de tous enfin façon on parle
on anime en même temps ou non mais je
comprends tout à fait que tu ailles
jouer les grandes chaînes pour pas cher
c'est en fait le truc c'est qu'il le
font tous oui oui
darty n'est pas les appels quand chez ce
tour qui finissent par se qualifier
ouvrait droit quelle progression en fait
il se trouve qu'il est un jeu où je suis
c'est ok mais ta ta ta remarque est que
quand il a joué en inde il a genre fini
dernier jory la joue en mode ça ne
m'intéresse pas méthode que ce que
c'était déjà fini les échanges je sais
pas encore mais j'arrive aurait pu jouer
la gagne pas max c'est vrai qu'il a joué
à fond à londres et je peux comprendre
il aurait loué m'embête le plus grand
reproche c'est même pas sûr donc chez
toi comme ça c'est que cette histoire en
fait un double circuit
ouais c'est ça le problème avec sa fille
et piketty pour les candidats un autre
qui sert à rien pour les candidats c'est
ça le problème en fait je dois faire un
circuit gehrig hâtif et tu fais une
sorte de fusion des deux miles et dont
on parle est au tout début juin mais ça
sera du sens même s'il faut faire on en
parlera sûrement là il y a
c'est juste logique cfa cédric normal vu
de loin qui parlent plus n'ont même pas
ce dont on parle moins deux ans mois
après je connais pas en fait qui qui
s'entend mal avec qui qui veut faire
concurrence à qui ou quoi faire parce
que peut-être des histoires comme ça que
en fait c'est un circuit qui veut tuer
l'autre où je sais pas ça peut être
aussi strict mais juste si tu prends
aucun intérêt personnel aucun intérêt de
rien abstral herbe de loin ça paraît
logique tu fais la qualif sur huit
tournois du tournoi lors des points est
ok à la fin clairement tu as les huit
meilleurs oui mais ça ce serait beau ça
les lumières sur deux ans peuvent lui
dire mais non ça ce serait ça ça
évidemment je suis d'accord avec toi ça
c'est déjà le problème numéro 1 on est
100 % d'accord c'est ça c'est le serveur
le parc d'olhain on en revient
finalement à la phrase qu'on avait en
conclusion notre discussion ya trois
quatre jours dont blame the players
blame the game final les joueurs qui
s'adaptent à ce qui se passait le
problème c'est les circuits plus que
plus qu'autre chose je trois joueurs et
c'est vrai que c'est marrant parce que
c'est vrai que du coup c'est le circuit
le moins prestigieux qui est le plus
rémunérateur
donc là aussi il ya ya ya ya un vrai
c'est un sujet dont il ya dix ans
probable c'est que la force ils
deviennent plus posthume je pense pas
ben je veux dire un moment afin de
mettre l'argent dans un truc ça finit
pas franchement si ici dans 20 ans fait
tatum qui joue ça et qu'ils délaissent
l'autre enfant sinon plus prestigieux
corps force
non mais la personne qui les laisse rien
pour l'instant
mais je veux dire peut-être qu'un jour
tu seras obligé est ce qu'il y aura de
plus en plus de tournois les tua tribune
l'a pour l'instant encore cinq six
tournois avec journaux 15 ans les sept
jours tout faire
ouais complètement complètement après on
peut
ce que l'on veut mais les derniers gros
tout résultat de nouvelles c'est le
calva ya une semaine sa victoire contre
magnus quand même ouais non mais je peux
je peux je peux comprendre fâche qu'on
jettera elle a fait flasher 6
apparemment ce que j'ai pu mais alors
s'il est plein de coups du foie justice
et f3 pas il veut faire plus on prend il
faut f2 car l'on ait même pas mal de
noms mais je comprends tout à fait les
blés choix de maximin et merci à
cottereau nice pour pour le prime merci
et bonne impression
pas assez c'est difficile tout mais
qu'il ya un moment donné le titre du
grand de chasse ou rapportera plus que
celui de champion du monde des pilotes
moi j'y crois pas tout et 29 papa moi
j'y crois pas moi j'y crois pas ça j'y
crois pas pour pour une raison fab ouais
j'y croirai si le grand duché source est
un modèle économique et que derrière il
y avait une grande marque
je ne sais pas enfin on va pas citer de
marque qu'on n'est pas là ferait de la
pub pour des marques les genres des
grosses marques tu vois qui sponsorise
le game et que et que ça à un retour sur
investissement sur l'image et la gérer
les mecs ils ont fait un gros truc le
truc marche
il ya du gros sponsors il ya de la
grosse marque ça a marché mais là vu que
c'est du mécénat le gars il va tenir
combien et 15 ans 20 ans 30 ans 40 ans
tu as qu un jardin 40 ans le mec va
continuer et s est comme le tourrenc y
avait à côté de chez moi le melody amber
non pas le gars est d'envoyer de
l'argent envoyé d'argent ce truc là qui
était un super tournoi et c'est super et
c'est tant mieux enfin je suis le
premier est content c'est pas le chum
critique par rapport aux mécènes qui qui
donne c'est génial et ça ça aide le jeu
et c'est fantastique mais je vais
reparler vu que c'est ça c'est pas
viable à long terme donc je vois pas
comment ça peut détrôner un titre de
champion du monde
il suffit que le gaz disparaît c'est le
circuit disparaît avec non melty show
new skies ont nourri mais c'est clair
c'est que le grand duché sourcilleux
fille disparaît à bas plus dur en
question du jour au lendemain ou en tout
cas plus intel grande chasse tour mais
en fait je la même fin avant que de se
faire passer un titre de champion du
monde et va en falloir battait comme un
titre olympique en sport quand
j'exerçais par contre si amazon qui a vu
qu'on est sûr twitch bien et tu te dis
c'est le circuit amazon seul amazon
prime pro twitch prime pour seul c'est
fantastique et tout ça tout ça
ben là j'y crois parce que tu as amazon
qui vient c'est une grosse marque et e10
barba nous on nous fait le circuit en
fait ils ont quand même lourd d'arrêter
quoi oui mais en fait ils te disent bon
ben ya pas dix mille personnes qui
regardent quand le grand de chasse sur
un instant t mais on a un million et
demi de spectateurs enfin tu as et un
gros truc sert enfin il ya une vraie
raison bon là je te dis oui ça peut
détruire le titre de champion du monde
mais à l'heure actuelle je vois tu vois
je vois pas un truc perrin qui se
pérennise sur sur dix ans nantes ap déjà
cinq ans que ça existe
il ya cinq ans le grand duché sont on
arrive et on a dit on va tout casser
machin on va on va va dépoussiérer les
échecs ça va être génial ça va bientôt
passer à la télé les meilleurs
commentaires le meilleur match un bon
palmarès après cinq ans oui c'est comme
un être social
ah oui donc par tonne ha après c'est un
beau circuit 1 c'est bien et tout ça
mais ça ça sas
sap a créé cette hype est ce tu vois non
il ya cet ipad a été créé le mec qui qui
qui qui voit le mécénat qui est derrière
il va pas il le mec va pas finir il va
pas faire ça pendant 50 ans donc pour le
moment en tout cas le petit déclic pour
que ça devienne quelque chose que les
marques s'intéressent ou quoi il a pas
il n'est pas arrivé mais ça veut pas
dire qu'il n'arrivera pas mais à l'heure
actuelle pour le moment dans la
situation actuelle
pour moi ça peut pas dépasser les
championnats du monde après si demain
les tournois pour une raison x ou y qui
deviennent très populaire que ça se met
à passer à la télé peut-être eurosport
vois je cite au hasard en femme
eurosport ou quoi y'a spillane aux états
unis commencent à le passer à la télé
que tu as des marques qui rejoignent
signe que fils et cetera à là je te dis
oui c'est possible mais pas à l'heure
actuelle
n'at-on pas le modèle économique qui
tienne la route
bah non c'est pas possible ça me fait
penser aux start-up tu as des start up
des voix qui vient ils font des grosse
levée de fonds ils ont plein d'argent
ils sont très heureux palmarès après
cinq ans y faire mais ils ont perdu pas
ils ont rien fait en fait start-up
l'habitat les start up qui marche à la
start up qui marchent pas ils ont l'air
assez heureux listing que fils quand
même diagne badauds oui mais comme
dreyfus était heureux
quand il quand il faisait l'om et voilà
enfin été très heureux aussi faste et
très bien ben ali a pâti font pas ça
sous la menace ou contrainte ise ils
font ça qu'ils ont envie de le faire et
c'est tant mieux mais ce qui veut pas
dire que tu vas faire toutes les faims
genre comme nahed auger qui finançait le
nao chess club n'évoque un moment l
arrêter quoi en fait oui et puis quand
elle a fait je sais pas si elle a été
championne d'europe plusieurs fois je pu
rien de france chaque année
beau club de beaux locaux une sur le
tour a fermé fin le temps que ça existe
et ça a été très bien oui et puis et
puis c'est tant mieux mais mais juste ça
tient parce que les là en voyant le jour
où une lassitude dans les chats qui est
autre chose
d'autres projets oui dis donc je crois
que je vois moins la ligue des champions
disparaître si tu veux
quelle grande chaise pour emad yamani
les échecs seront jamais un supporter
l'équipe oui mais comme on me disait il
ya sept ans quand j'ai commencé la
chaîne les échecs ça fera jamais rien
sur twitch les assurés qui sera jamais
un sur youtube et tout ça va on m'a
expliqué traitera énormément de poids
qu'avait convoi à faire avec les échecs
que ça servait à rien et nanani nanana
enfin ça c'est un discours que j'entends
mais on a le droit de penser l' inverse
et au moins d'essayer en tout cas ce que
je vois c'est que aujourd'hui sur des
matches décisifs comme magnus maxime
vachier lagrave sans les images un
moment donné si tu cumules youtube et et
tweets on était quand même 5600 ou 6000
en français ce qui est plus très ce qui
est pas vraiment ridicule pour du tweet
chars évidemment c'est pas énorme non
plus mais c'est quand même un petit peu
quelque chose tu vas tu m'aurais
j'aurais dit ça il ya six ans on va
amener 6000 personnes pour garder une
partie de mvl sans les images on va être
signée il ya six ans tout le monde
aurait dit tu étais un fou bon ben il se
trouve que c'est possible alors
peut-être qu'il se trouve qu'en faisant
les choses très bien c'est possible de
passer à la télé il se trouve que c'est
possible de faire encore mieux enfin on
ne sait pas après un mais
ce que j'ai envie de dire c'est laisser
les gens qui croient faire des choses si
vous n'êtes de bâtons dans les roues et
pas tellement c'est ça après nous on
prend les échecs on aime bien on fait
beaucoup d'efforts pour ce soit fab ce
soit moi que ce soit mathieu que ce soit
vladou quoi on croit ce truc là on pense
que c'est possible de faire encore plus
avec les échecs et que c'est un beau jeu
après peut-être qu'on a tort qu'on est
con et des fous mais tout ça on a une
expression en russe il dit c'est parce
que il m'est souvent ça a été traduit ou
alors c'est les russes qui ont traduit
mais parce que s'ils savaient pas que
c'était pas pouces il ne savait pas que
c'était impossible alors ils l'ont fait
que vous avez juste ouais un ruisseau
six ans il danse et expression ne sache
pas où elle sort mais c'est un truc même
on prend ça quoi mais évidemment quand
tu totaux limites ce n'est plus du
retrait de choses bah après c'est
possible soirée j'ai passé une légende
ou pas ça mais genre quand tu veux dos
et un éléphant tu la tâche un petit
arbre de merde dont il est petit mais il
peut pas bouger quoi
et après et puis en fait il grandit
grandit grandit bon moment la petite la
petite fille celle de merde ils
n'auraient pas pâti dans la ville et
hellebuyck en fait ça n'a jamais marché
qu'il essaye même plus en fait il reste
la bloquer ouais vas tu la tâche avec un
bloc de l'est moins un truc il bouge le
petit doigt et j'enlève mes du coup
comme il a été formaté pour notre pas le
bouger ben ben c'est pareil en fait la
force de tribus et ça marchera pas ça
marchera pas ça marchera pas bah oui ça
peut marcher
vous imaginez mise cette émission vidéo
à la télé il y a un coup à jouer toutes
les 38 arrêts mais nous on change la
carence en fait germain donc en fait du
coup non il va y avoir un coup joué
toutes les minutes au minimum un bon si
vous cumulez en france ses abonnés alors
c'était bien acheté catalan de rajouter
la chaîne vite stream parce que là tu
cumules plusieurs chaînes tu as dix
mille personnes tu mets bitstream seul
tu es déjà 34 min tu vois donc j'ai
envie de te détruire et si qq pas de
stream switcher bitstream youtube déjà
cinquante mille personnes donc là
peut-être mais bitstream seul en fait et
or un chiffre plus important c'est un
conseil après c'est si tu veux faire un
chiffre plus gonflé c'est pas idiot
non mais c'est vrai fan alors au bout
d'un moment il se trouve pour les vidéos
youtube osi ce match le nombre de gens
qui regardent des vidéos c'est peut-être
plus intéressant de vente juste les
audiences bitstream sol je vais quand
même pas tous lui prévoyait en fait
juste bitstream fautif tu déjà vu juste
du cannabis trouvée c'est sûr mais
planté tout le temps j'ai vu de jeu pour
élever le débat dont j'ai dit bon on
commence par les mardis puisqu'on a
montré tout à l'heure il ya juste vers
3h un orage de l'iran qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pour autant se faire planter
le site de tv5 hâtif est peut-être
l'arbitré on était très heureux pourtant
le vitrage fabre watch un jeu de tempo
par mon épaule biologique 1 toulouse 34
32 choc
maintenant c'est fini à faire déjà tu n
as plus on prend un f4 là quand même
assez fortement
enfin cherpion préemption prend ou f2
kh2 tour g1 ya rien n'y a pas d' attaque
un peu montré un homme joue devant l
admettront confech paroisse e set j'ai
pu faire un truc pour tripler vitæ clé
avec les noms à montbard et j'ai pas et
c'est avec les blancs de faire quoi que
ce soit mais c'est déjà fini
il n'y a pas d' attaque et et sur
cavaliers g6 mon qui revient bâche 4 et
on va prendre angers 5 et choix brouille
de juifs aussi vite relâchés fut séduite
bon je crois qu'ils vont avoir beau
moment où il nous aura fait plaisir
quand ils ont chois quoi maximiles
possibilité d'avoir la wild card 0,1
pour cent fera un petit tweet gens peu
instruits dans la dépression notre seul
n'y crois pas trop à jeanne qui peut
d'ailleurs regagné via le concours
bitstream à de pronostic il peut gagner
un abonnement d'un an diamant à thiès
comme hulu ou la salade iso sur le pion
isolé s'il préfère
dong dong donc et la fête gf et gf et je
ne suis pas fou ou rouge et un tassement
il a pas encore versé clair tu va
retirer son fou auquel alors dit celui
qui prend 1,4 pressé de mettre un peu de
suspense si on prend et d'alger 5
oui dushku juin toutes plus précis ouais
d'accord tu fais pas trop de suspense à
jouer préfet prend b6 on défend ils ont
de bons jeux dont vous êtes un géant
pour l'instant il prend et jusqu'à
voyage de bon y'a nepton chanteuse aux
besoins de cet acte à combien de sion
pour les normes qui tu vas voir trois
pions pour les noirs mais faible en
qualité
t'as pas les attaques web on peut
arriver à l'agencé bon tour j'ai aussi
je trouve qu'on peut défendre des 6 7 6
tu veux faire dame 17 et 5 et tout au
tout doux c'est mais normalement je vais
leur débat tant de péchés il a fini avec
gm chef du jem j'ai fait pour l'instant
il n'a pas encore joué mais la foule
bien tu dis beaucoup plus fort est
évalué à 4,4 d'amis ici juste fois je
fais preuve de hockey première faute du
joueur russe se fasse à la ruine fab
il joue très vite en fait les plouffe ça
peut jeu des tours le problème c'est que
ma demande qu'on a vu malheureusement ce
type pas encore décisif mais s'avère
moins bons mois juste c'est moi précis
j'ai une petite page de pub à bon pour
faire monter la pression
allez petite page
soit c'est nul moi je m'appelle paul
rufisque on va voir fabrier rien n'est
encore fait bah non en tant que ce n'est
pas signé on écoute on va se battre
jusqu'au bout quoi quand on peut et on
dit ça fout les boules
le numéro 4 mondial qui n'est pas aux
candidats veille et plus numéro quatre
mondial justement voyez attentes et
l'ouverture interdite mais il attendait
bien c'est beau quand on nous dit qu'il
avantage noir après fouet f2 à
s'échapper
ferrer n'est pas comment mais ce serait
beau petit calibre et à grands pas daba
mu fantastique pour tous les impôts
plein pour plein de raisons à tous les
niveaux non ils disent que c'est pour
maxime pour la rize pour nous portent
elles vraiment lila est très pessimiste
après tout f2 jeudi vont faire quel
point 4 obligé il donne 15 % seulement
de chances de gain au noir c'est mieux
que rien mais c'est mieux que rien fan
on est dans lequel joue pas qu'ils
avaient il prend 1,4
le reste c'est tu donc déjà 5% il est
bon il va peut-être 4 juste un petit
truc tout à l'heure avant le match je
regarde je regarde le match de rugby
poke pour stade français juste un moyen
non mais c'est même pas drôle en fait
pour raconter un truc et à un gars qui
s'appelle arrêt qui s'appellerait
reymi42 heures à chaque fois qu'il
touche le ballon et réseaux et l'appel
enfin passe pour rake wafa il
appellerait à fond c'est peut-être avec
du faux faucon et produits longs cils
balancerait souvent dans le match quand
même des gars were here et conteste
dorée quoi bon compte est de fait mais
il le dit vraiment oreilles je vois ça
m'a rendu heureux
enfin ça n'a aucun intérêt mais pas j'ai
le droit
donc et non tous pelles et les choses
que tu as que tu as raconté sont pas
vrai que tarek autant entendu sont pas
vraies le il appelait rei après je suis
je connais plus le prénom du ga rei avec
un air mais bon il faut bien comme
houston d'urines ouais tu m'appelles pas
le rail le stade du ray sergei k sur son
trade michel non ouais non je n'arrive
pas à supporter la non-qualification des
mères est fait honnêtement les gars j'ai
vraiment du mal à regarder la partie
shayk fab on n'analyse pas du tout et
c'est parce qu'enfin pour preuve c'est
qu'en fait d'aller dans ce sens très mal
enfin le seul truc voilà bon aussi nous
ont fait un petit bilan comme ça y'a une
pièce demain bon ça c'est donc le seul
chance d'attaquer comme des oufs
sinon les blancs rouges fermer la
position qui aura rien à voir c'est pour
ça que l'ordi foncier qui prend 1,4 avec
l'idée de faire passer à dambach g5 et
donc menacer m'attend j'ai de bons mais
du coup pour les blancs défendent faut
virer le fou de f2 et il faut prendre
les six plus ou moins un pas con parce
que au moins au passage on prend un pion
bon on prend ça menace m'attend j'ai un
rêve le cavalier mais en fait c'est ce
qu'on adapte à leur surprenante 5e en
réalité à tanger intermédiaire
intermédiaire il fait mal donc vous
prenez 5 la même pas en réalité le moto
club qatarien c'est +3 et abandon voilà
enfin du coup voyez pas analysé 5,3 h3c
pour dire tout reprend mais c'est une
tour contre la donne oui bah le problème
c'est qu'en fait tu n'es peut proposer
mieux à ce moment là par exemple
et puis normalement juste accepte si
c'était une position là où nul qualifié
mvl et tous âges sont serait pas là
enfin c'est quand même complètement
foutu mon serait pas le mode d'hier
s'est perdue mais là il faut comprendre
que les blancs en plus ont besoin que de
faire nul mais
sinon on pourrait dire oui à peut-être
un peu de jeu et peut-être qu'il peut
sauver la nulle tirs étaient closes mais
là nul nul ne suffit pas donc après
c'est complètement fini fins et il n'y a
pas grand chose à raconter
mais ashton did was not prime annuelle
oui bah il a pas de raison mais le jour
où tu t'es vraiment foutu battu prend
cinq points elo en fat man next en hulk
paris mais les cowboys à dire c'est
aller un peu vite se retrouver très vite
et l'un et l'autre on y bosse habituel
oui c'est un peu aussi pitt et s'être
chauffé trop vite avec les cinq bons
pourtant tu vois qu'il faut noter qu on
t'emmène mais après je peux non mais je
grossis en fait ils considèrent que le
match est plus que mal engagée pas sûr
quand tu perds à clément la première
ronde
j'ai pas j'ai un plan plus personnel
mais non match comme ça mais vous et
voilà après j'ai un match en tête peut
être les noirs sont venus d'affilée
c'est un ivan tchouktche toschi en coupe
du monde quelques années
sous top spin ils vont tous via clé d'or
vous la pire qu est juste aussi moins 8
ans voilà l'attaqué autrichienne un truc
super tendu non mais comme d'hystérie
loved en chat surtout qui sert tu peux
prendre la nouvelle avec les noms mais
oui il m'a dit ressaisir ce jour plus
qu'aujourd'hui il est possible de
boycott de la russie vu le dopage
non non mais surtout que ces histoires
de boycott de machin en fait c'est dans
des événements qui seront qui seront
dans longtemps peut-être quand c'est
prévu dans un élément qui s'organise en
trois mois tu peux pas tout changer même
les olympiades qui seront en août je
pense qu'ils n'ont pas le changer alors
d'après ce que j'ai lu et de la fidh
s'ils n'ont ni a changé il n'y a ni l'un
ni l'autre parce que c'est pas dans des
les organisateurs sont déjà décidées et
changer d'organisation est trop
compliquée entre guillemets et donc ils
peuvent le garder en revanche je crois
qu'à des événements 2022 ou 2023 qui
pourrait être remis en cause
oui mais voilà du coup il était vraiment
temps de sa 2022 tu te dis bon j'ai
quand même trois ans pour changer
trouver quelqu'un d'autre un local bien
où il ya des hôtels ou des choses pour
pour accueillir les joueurs peut-être
d'autres sont donc tu peux
éventuellement revenir sur tes pattes là
en fait quelque chose il rêve dans trois
mois comment comment faire
surtout aucune olympiades haute à des
milliers des milliers de joueurs qui
viennent
il avoue quand même avoir les
infrastructures pour les héberger tu
peux pas vraiment pas faire ça n'importe
où si tu doit héberger des gens à 50km
marche pas trop quoi non c'est dur c'est
dur non mais je vois pas le truc un peu
dommage plus dans cette position c'est
que je vois pas vraiment gaffe toutes
les variantes sont forts ces genres qui
prend un pion prend dame g5 c'est quand
même fort le soir même si tu veux on
veut s'il faut prendre ici ça va juste
ultra logis l'imitateur voyage demain si
la vallée à jeu c'est juste super
logique tu as deux favoris et à tour
gyan prochain du coup tu vois quand même
que vous progressez un qui à tour g1
facile voilà ce qu'est masse est simple
avoir purgé ans il menace non mais quand
même tu dois pas en plus même la fois
pour 925 dames 35 ans de notre groupe
mais seule fois c'est que même en jouant
un coup vraiment mauvais c'est quand
même mieux oui hélas au prochain tu fais
est de toute façon à ce moment là quand
tu arrives dans la position tu vois tour
g1 il est donc avec les noirs chez
patufets dame f6 en premier puis on peut
même prendre ces huit prend dans ses 8
et afr torchère mais il vous sert une
pièce de viande et du temps les trois tu
te bats mais en fait est qu'un pion pour
la pièce comme ses pains de pions appui
et non un pilon a donc fait je sais pas
combien en bullet tu peux attaquer et
surtout gamme el idha me2me genre lui
l'a fait il a fait un calibre en quatre
c'était sur 100 c'est la seule option
sur le tour date yves mais c'est une
tentative est c'est lorsque finalement
on aura dit la partie quasiment à
l'avance sauf le moment où il a vraiment
très mal joué avec les bras ouais je
sais pas faim en fait sont caillage de
fusil 4,5 ses soucis et finalement est
ce que le tournant de la saison c'est
pas à l'élimination de navarra en demi
finale ben doté pour la wii
bref le héros mais ouais bon en fait
pour le coude mais pourra-t-on faire
avec nous un portillon finale mais n'est
pas une arme favori il fait un séjour 60
45 35
l'armée yaris et voilà où l'autre
d'ailleurs il s'est vraiment envoyer en
l'air hier comme un idiot wyss et
ségalas non mais ce qu'il a fait c'est
dégueulasse non mais c'est courageux de
sa part
enfin c'est inconscient ou sydney oui et
là ils essaient de gagner il donne tout
ce qu'il a quoi toi fan pris comme ça on
peut pas lui en vouloir il faut prendre
le caté materi oui mais faut croire qu
as tu vas très bien qu'il a fait pour
moi je crois qu'il va pas oui tu vas pas
te faire sa sauce et cisco netapp ou g2
qui arrête tu peux pas faire sans la
vérifier en france et sur d'apple
apparaît la variante dhabi g5 publicis
qui avec l'autre
l'auteur peut-être d'autres il faut
prendre soin de son corps puis on prend
je comprends et donne juste un oui comme
ça mais au moins tu as été le tour g1
est imprimé à oui tu as tu la tête
mais le truc ce qu'on a dit que même ça
ça n'est pas trop mais avec déjà c'est
sûrement une version mignon mais il a
fait d'un g5 toute façon directe et
d'accord alors vu six jours avant mal
non peut-être vu ci est désespéré
maintenant fin prêt
en fait quand tu as pu le coeur je
cherche même pas les finesses des ordres
de coups je sais pas s'il a réfléchi
longtemps et doit être déprimé arrive on
sait j'ai perdu en 15 minutes donc de
manger 5 jouer mon nom est ce que oui ou
d'infirmer si je suis quasi sûr qu'il
trouvait m
tu peux peut-être faire fujitsu etc soit
moins bien en plus quand ils pensent le
truc de maxime c'est que pour commenter
la dernière ronde de lier semaine qui
ouais moi
et je suis en train de le rappeler le
scénario de la dernière ronde américaine
fin avec cinq coups ils sont jusqu'à la
mort ça oui bon après ski facile ou
qu'ils gagnent et finissez deuxième mais
quand tu y penses sûr eu un autre mec
qui aurait gagné ce qui avait dit avait
des cas qui est en situation de me swing
de partout et aurait pu avoir un mec en
must win qui gagne parce qu'en fait
c'était blanc doit de massereene warboys
massereene taille aurait pu avoir un
gachi crânien le swing je suis pas il a
le droit quand même et bah du coup alex
enhco il fini fini 3e et ya pas de
russes éligibles à la wild card et on
passe mais en fait non 1 quand tu y
penses même cette dernière on le
scénario il est il a free il a fallu
beaucoup de choses quand même je sais
mêmes howell qui s'envoient en l'air tu
as vu calexico étant sûr il peut plus
gagné de tournoi sinon peut-être que à
l'iccn qu il gagne sa partie conduite
yougov aurait aussi été emmené au swing
et du coup ça alex est une co qui passe
c'est ou en gallo première premier
éligibles wild card et c'est de nouveau
maximum quand tu y penses c'est de
nouveau un cas de figure où les étoiles
ne s'aligne vraiment pas non mais ce qui
s'est passé si tu t'es un mec tu le
quittes annoncent à il ya un an que ça
tu prends aussi par un malade mental
c'est une probabilité infinie alexeï
kokine devant aronian à un point et
l'aude et partage lui aussi un mec quand
tu additionne tous les tous les trucs
c'est quand même hallucinant
après sa dépression qui moi je dis
hamdouallah pas trois fois topalov au
grand prix c'est pas la même non plus
n'y a pas à se plaindre
çà çà çà çà çà c'est vrai que christine
non mais tu as autant que l'on peut être
mauvais c'est évidemment vers été bon
dans ce à quoi il aurait pu passer
congrès plein de couteaux le faut si oui
oui mais évidemment tout poloff fabien
veyriras maxime parce que témoin d'un
goût puisqu'il était une époque et en
plus au style de jeu correspond bien
maxime oui donc le tout cumulé c'est un
très bonne affaire ça on demande surtout
prend b6 pourquoi pas
f5 maintenant oui possible dans cet
ordre là aussi la voir pour éviter que
ces prophéties sur les possibles si ce
n'est du coup faire cadeau d'échanger
leurs stocks
c'est ce dont on a déjà parlé mais on va
avoir ce genre d'opposition mais sur un
ça va
elle va avoir deux ans pour étoffer son
répertoire il lui manque
si peu de chose en vrai mais ça fait une
énorme 10 c'est vrai aussi peut-être que
dans ces matches décisifs au delà du
côté mental dont on a déjà parlé le
manque
deux surprises peut peut-être jouer au
minimum comme ça que j'entends parler
avec la ddt au minimum avoir l'option de
faire douter l'adversaire qui doivent
préparer deux choses ça peut aussi être
un adhérent fin qu on est beau ce que
deviendra fou des quatre oui bagarre ça
marche et ça a très bien marché sous
produit très bien très vite le jeu pas
étonnant non je les porte au dessus
d'une croire que wade doivent avoir le
la cam ou quoi donc c'est vrai que ça
pourrait aussi aider mais à
mais bon après sur le scénario de
l'année il avait 90% de chances d'y
aller un nom mais en fait juste en
niveau intrinsèque c'est rien à dire
pince ces flamands j'ai pensé à un match
de nadal contre garcia-lopez prévu ou
nadal rade 21h21 balles de break et
après bon voire fou juste il craque
ce qui est rarissime mais bon il rata
ira des balles de break sur fouche pas
l'autre mains coudes dans un coup droit
let qui tombent dedans qui passe le fils
va se dire que sur les vingt-et-une il y
en a peut-être 4,5 l'autre à une chance
incroyable et nadal ont monté salsoul et
il perd le match
aujourd'hui s'apaise on peut trouver ça
se passe comme ça
vraiment tu vois le truc arriver mais le
web en tout cas en sport enfin d'amendé
et le manque de réalisme c'est vrai tu
as plein d'occasions foot que tu marche
pas mais hyper sûr tu te prends un
corner pourri au tennis quand à 10
balles de break temps mais pas une mais
tu vas te perdre le tie-break mathieu
sapin c'est tout le temps comme ça en
fait ouais tu le sens mais surtout que
ça arrive vraiment souvent enfin je
pense
il y avait un autre match comme ça cette
année c'était à l'open d'australie quand
on fait d'ailleurs perdu contre city
pass à huy by la royale balle de break
il n'en a pas mille une participation à
une par poitiers s'est durcie techlid
technique oui mais tu es du wes
arrivants tellement match tellement
tellement tellement et oui c'est le
réalisme
elle est la coupe du monde de foot on a
été quand même ultra réaliste à la
france sont notés cette année est la
stratégie quand même contre attaqua mba
p il veut bien nous demande c'est quoi
ce tournoi sunwise si jesse bassin sur
nos panneaux fait si des gestes concrets
de barcelone et voilà tout est juste je
crois que c'est ce que mes partenaires
dorine qu ils ont ils ont dû en faire un
peu la pub ou bien le diffuser bien le
mettre en avant c'est à faro peine ils
ont comme ambition de devenir le nouveau
gibraltar pour l'instant ce n'est pas
encore le cas gibraltar est de loin le
plus fort au pétrin d'assassinât il aux
fans en fait mais je dirais donc
gibraltar ça reste quand même énorme
truc à il a fait cavalier 3 attends
attends attends attends attends il
affirmé
l'ordi d'un égal fab ouais mais
peut-être que mélanger mal à rester sur
un pc sur in perpète parce qu'il donne à
f prends ça prend g g iii fou prend h6
et d'ananas m a forcé n'a peut-être
qu'il a fait l'exploit des premières de
la poule
parce que sinon tu fais tour g1 était
obligé de prendre perpète et donc
cavalier 3 quant à un moyen de pop on
aperçoit enfin non impossible sans
suicidé jeudi
non il veut faire tour j'ai un nom mais
je cherche pas je comprends et surtout
nombreux trois fous pro 3 dames g3
franchissons un autre il faut prendre
trois là tu peux tenter d'un match 4 si
tu veux tenter quelque chose
oui messieurs processus c'est cool pro
europe soit 5 m et quand bien même web
avec les noms soient pas jouer l'idiot
faire sa ba majorie moment là tu vas pas
faire ça donc tu vas faire fou prend ses
huit tours prend ses 8 et damages de et
tours j'ai 3
2 ça calme ok et dames g3 du coup la
revente que l'ordi donne pour fermer et
surtout près de cinq pour 3 il a tout
calculé c'est sur wii un jeu
on imagine il est fort quand même
non mais la dépouille il avait juste un
neil a été dit a pas mal calculé qu'on
me faisait pas mal qu'elle tue et la
jouer vite et où la pression est
d'ailleurs ce qui est bien joué de la
part donnée pose c'est que j'y rentre
dans la variante où ils forcent à soi
c'est plus de 4 + 5 c'est fini soit ces
personnels nuls direct et c'est bien
joué puisque l'autre il a que plus de 5
ans est complètement gagnant et là ils
te dis ok ufo trois autres bannières
faut prendre 6 mai à ces feux données de
trois roches dos d'homme je trouve mon
père nous sommes très bien joué même
même l'année peau il a été propre un
jeune gitan damev pas à ouidah mais
trois rouages de fou prend f5 ya
toujours trois de nouveau n'est survenu
le signe ont beaucoup à dire enfin bon
ça c'est hier que se jouer aujourd'hui
bah quoi dire bravo déjà à brobo de
dépôt bravo année peau ça c'est quand
même quelque chose fait qu'on a envie de
dire en premier lieu et moi je vais
faire mon tweet qu'elle aille rechercher
ce que où ils étaient déjà préparés
ouais j'ai préparé le mans 2 1 attends
j'ai préparé mon tweet du coup tu veux
soutien massif pour faire changer d'avis
la fidh
non mais non en fait je vais à la fille
de leur nom il va pas y avoir de
changement pour cette fois cela ça mon
avis ça va pas marcher pour cette fois
là pour être honnête mais je me dis que
ça peut peut-être changer pour pour les
prochaines fois ça marche des fois non
mais je lis ça peut faire changer pour
pour la prochaine fois et est alors
attends faut juste
il faut juste que que je récupère le
twitter officiel de greffe et des russes
que je vais trouver facilement parce que
parce que je fais russophones et que du
coup alors oui c'est ça oui on fait moi
faire un copier-coller nice ont fait le
cd revues de hausse
on dort score ok j'en vois le broyage et
m'a dit didier à toulon ce que c'est le
tweet tweet le deuil des larmes si derek
l'élite l'origine des parties des gens
m'ont paul n'ont pas twitter tu sais
très bien
le tweet le tweet est partie l'élite le
tweet est parti et je vais mettre je
vais mettre le lien du tweet sûr surtout
que je twitte et partis dont vous pouvez
retweeter ou pas d'ailleurs ça dépend si
vous croyez au truc fait faites comme
vous voulez en réalité coûté si vous
voulez retweet pour ce que vous pensez
que ce serait cool d'avoir match pour la
wild card mais surtout pour que ça
puisse changer des choses dans le futur
je mets un petit bien c'est plus ça
parce que pour cette fois ci je donne
une chance sur mille pour que ça change
quelque chose
mais peut-être que au moins
dans à tanger pas j'ai pas mis le truc
dans le bon chat mais peut-être que dans
deux ans ou quoi ça peut ça peut ça peut
quand même changé des choses la
communauté c'est important et montrer
que qu'il ya des gens qui s'intéressent
aux échecs et qui veulent changer les
choses ça peut ça peut montrer que qu'il
ya des gens qui regardent les échecs et
qui voudraient quelque chose de plus
normal va peut-être même en volant j'ai
les wild cards en réalité fabre vous
faire un comité de choix du wild card ou
en tout cas changer un peu loin mais ça
doit être carte de soi en soit je suis
contre le problème c'est que c'est un
peu notre carte tu as peut-être pas dans
des hôtels donc bon moment tu as envie
de les organiser des candidats donc tu
dis bon ben ça moindre mal d'avoir bombe
à une loi de card avec un mec et qu'elle
méritait plus ou moins sa place en iran
puis quelques conditions et qui ça ils
vont pas prendre 13 cents lots non plus
voilà mes de base en fait moi je suis
juste content rewatt car le bassin
versant
il ya des gens qui pensent que c'est
plutôt que c'est un peu un côté forcé
pour l'organisation le lait les gars
disent que c'est m veulent perdre parce
que je propose qu'un match contre alex
enhco mvl en fait je compose pas qu'on
donne la wild card mv je propose qu'on
organise un match et du coup les mecs
mais tu imagines qui perdent le match
contre l excellent que oui on veut on
peut rien y faire
mais pourquoi le tout à la fédé russe
que c'est eux qui décident je pense
sinon ils leur ont passé ils ne verront
pas assez bon bah ça changera
probablement rien mais à mes bons mais
il est russe çi dessus oui je suis au
courant mais bon peut-être que les gens
voient le tweet et puis se disent
pas pour cette fois là mais peut-être
ils se disent dans deux en quatre ans
c'est vrai que pareil si on dit jamais
rien et qu'on se plaint qu entre nous et
cetera j'ai envie de dire de toute façon
enfin oui mais c'est pas une faute en
vain bien ça mange pas de pain il sert à
rien ce sera quelque chose mais de rien
faire ça servira à rien de toute façon
donc soit tu es sur st dupont tout près
après après tu peux ne rien faire et
puis et puis quand tu auras la retraite
à 75 ans ben tu dirais à la retraite à
75 ans enfin c'est pas grave tu ne fais
jamais rien ça ne change jamais rien
donc pas parce que l'on ne fait jamais
rien jamais je pense que j'ai enfin oui
bon la monarchie ça me saoule
on peut rien changer et qu'enfin ne
faisons rien ou qui ont fait rien
geignard 1,58
non mais là c'est on peut pas on peut
pas on peut pas comparer la révolution
un tweet mais je veux dire par là que ça
c'est toujours pareil c'est comme les
échecs ça peut jamais être populaire
donc ça sert à rien d'essayer de faire
quelque chose a tout changé les trucs la
wild card votre façon peut pas le faire
donc faisons enfin j'ai j'en ai marre de
tout le temps en 30 ça évidemment ça va
rien changer
là maintenant ce truc là mais peut-être
que si on n'est pas quelque chose et au
pire en pire ça sert à rien basse tave à
quoi t'as pas gâcher ta vie à vouloir
faire soit ajustée un tweet de prix 45
secondes ouhlala oui
et s'il ya beaucoup de gens qui pensent
la même chose et que et que la wild card
il soit il doit pu en avoir soi elle
doit être donnée différemment bas au
pire ça fera changer les règles pour
dans deux ans quatre ans ou quoi non
mais enfin je vois pas ce que ça peut
faire de mal en réalité soit ces
socialos et bien soit ça change rien et
c'est pas les points négatifs
non non bonnet qui je comprends pas
pourquoi ils prennent pas les huit
meilleurs lots un oui mais en fait quoi
qu'il en soit les histoires de vélo
c'est pas tellement de la perte se
serait bien passé on a déjà parlé
ça va être le vélo savent prendre la
moyenne et l'eau se vaporise le mec qui
avait beaucoup de vélo au début du truc
jarre mamediarov café y passer alors
qu'il fait nan est dégueulasse
il avait de 1820 en fait dans sa moyenne
sont 2008 en a tout le temps compter
puis même qu'on s'est mis à fondre à
perdre du vélo il est passé de 2008 s'en
va à 2760 d'un coup il a d'abord eu de
1810 puis de 1800 puis 27 95 peut-être
qu'il est un peu restée là puis 27 90
puis est donc en fait il a fait que
berne
et puis ben il va être qualifié la
moyenne alors sa perte sur l'année je ne
sais pas quand même peut-être qu'il est
à peine à 2700 et que tu as vingt mecs
vont plus que lui il n'y a pas de raison
qu'ils profitent d'un vélo qu'il ya deux
ans pour ce qui est fait dans un truc
qui a lieu deux ans plus tard ou alors
faudrait prendre au moins à la perf sur
deux ans ou sur sur deux ans que le
cycle les deux ans en plus pourquoi ils
voient la moyenne que sur un an
d'ailleurs bonsoir
mais du coup spots à moi même je pense
que le match comme moi je pense la perte
sur deux ans mais après il ya des gens
qui jouent plus de tiges ou moins ce
truc de lots on en revient au même
problème que tout à l'heure les gars
c'est de dire ce qu'on dise avec fabien
sait qu'il faudrait que le circuit du
grande chaise tour en tout cas qui est
un grand circuit où tu as tout un
tournoi qui ce qui se réunissent où tu
marques des points et que ce soit
choisie sur dix 12 tournois dans l'année
mais d'ailleurs peut-être que dans ces
cas là si c'était comme ça fabuleux est
même plus de match pour le championnat
du monde il aurait peut-être juste comme
au tennis par exemple ou au go un
circuit yeux sur l'année et un numéro 1
mondial à la fin de la saison
cette fois je n'étais pas mousse peu
importe mais mal d'occasions de moi
j'aime bien
par tradition pour tout ce que ça
représente
voilà c'est pas le truc ultime se battre
ça ne faire que le champion du monde
un privilège de rester anti de machin je
ne sais pas ça c'est discutable même bon
de bas je veux pas leur faire
fondamentalement ça me dérange pas mais
voilà mais est ce que je veux dire tu as
et comme les yeux que c'est une course
enfin jarre le 100 m j'ai haussé tient
une course ici huit secondes à une photo
et 90 secondes une fois tous les quatre
ans et c'est le titre ultime ayad aux jo
c'est ça il ya deux choses ces cinq
secondes quelques fois par semaine la c8
secondes une fois tous les quatre ans
voilà j'ai en lui dire faut mieux être
en forme sur les huit secondes
exactement cette grosse performance quoi
aller ont fait effet il faut finir sur
un petit peu d'humour fabre m
ouais bah ouais écoute toi tu fais quoi
rendez vous du coup c'est bientôt je
viens du monde rapide et blitz ouais
c'est du 26 au 30 ce sera ici ou sur
l'oss pas ici ce sera ici on espère
faire surtout maxime charrette en fait à
l'aise total born to follow mais fatigue
c'est ce qu'annonce non mais là ça il
vient lui il a le temps elle attend se
ressourcer mon petit ami kyle ash 95
jours était chaude non j'ai vu la
déception nadal a déjà rien que manager
je sache ça donc ça va être mon avis
difficile mais bon il y aura des belles
parties il y aura il y aura du magnus y
aura du maxsym ce sera ce sera sympa un
peu tout le monde
hikaru et peut-être je sais pas j'ai pas
j'ai pas vérifié série car les niches du
sol est allé vallée du jourdain mondiale
ont blessé j'ai royal c'est parti ce
n'est pas un athlète c'est un avatar
d'internet allez comprendre ce type
n'est pas un athlète un peu de pédagogie
sur ma chaîne wii vous pouvez si vous me
suivez sur twitter et sur facebook
maintenant on fait un calendrier toutes
les semaines donc vous aurez un
calendrier des stream qui va qui va
sortir
ben je le mettrai en ligne demain il
sort d'avoir le le petit lac calendrier
donc vous pouvez aller soit sur facebook
soit sur twitter et vous trouverez le
calendrier des scream qui sont sûrs
après il peut y avoir des stream qui
sont rajoutés ou qui commencent plus tôt
ou quoi mais sait on peut pas on peut
pas changer le calendrier tous les jours
et faire des tweets et vous vous noyez
sous les tweets donc on en fait on en
fait un par semaine et puis c'est à des
petites modifications de façon j'ai
écrit sur twitter ou sur facebook
bon je sais pas j'ai du mal à arrêter le
stream la femme parce qu'il ya quand
même beaucoup de frustration je ne le
cache pas
camille guen ont même prôné enfin au
moment où on va on va sortir en douceur
tu as mais je garde encore trois quatre
minutes le truc parce que je n'ai pas eu
mal là j'ai du mal parce que en fait je
sais pas si ça te le fais parfois mais
pour moi arrêter le stream là en réalité
au moment où le stream sera arrêté
maxime sera vraiment éliminer
tu as donc quand je veux
on sait par an encore notre chance je ne
sais pas le stream est là donc quelque
part c'est un truc qui dure depuis
maintenant quelques mois depuis juillet
a eu énormément de stream le stream est
encore ouverte tu vois assez voilà on
est encore au moment là où je fais
arrêter me quitte jamais ouais le mont
le stream à arette ça veut dire qu'il va
voir attendre encore un an et demi pour
que le prochain cycle comment ça c'est
vraiment la fin de quelque chose ou
alors radjabov peut-être radja bas mais
ça on saura pas de sitôt mais est ce
qu'on allait voir
s'il vient pas ce sera forcément une
bonne nouvelle pour maximum après le
truc c'est kevin ans a tronqué pour sa
préparation mais bon on va te dire qu'on
prend est-ce qu'on fait une grosse
soirée siradj à l'un des forfaits
confiance wines
non mais si les forfaits de ski sans
fouille si les forfaits pour les dons de
médicaments vous passerez jaunards n'ont
dans ces cas là mais on a bien sûr bien
sûr bien sûr tu as raison de recadrer
fab
si c'est pour raisons médicales non
franchement franchement non franchement
non et j'espère que les gens bien folle
ou la chaîne à fond et tout un
que ce soit sur youtube / / / twitch de
partout bob c'est en fait il ya encore
plein d'événements donc loctudy leurs
affidés blitz à son égard des candidats
qui seront suivis par les candidats à
partir de mars 1 donc bon voila j'ai
envie de te dire
ni bon voila voila ss et plâtre voila
voila mon père eddie voili voilou je
crois pourtant fait je bosse je bosse
sucre sur l'ancienne chose oui mais tu
peux dire il peut te dire à l'eau à lui
le faron cct truc à la mode
oui ok boomers à entendre un médecin
puis le jour d'halloween fusils à l'eau
il te dis oui enfin bon c'est
insupportable j'en peux plus la jeune et
jolie ville où j'ai entendu je connais
cette belle expression très bien voili
voilou voili voilou non mais y ait des
passions qu'on n'utilise plus tôt george
comme un truc qui facilite geste et
fastoche massage aux ministres mais ça
fait 20 ans que j'ai pu entendu sur quoi
elle ça fait boum boum boum ça par
contre oui ça c'est bien mais on peut
dire que c'est plate le prélat falloir
t'y sap répondent fait avant la chanson
une nouvelle fois on s'en va il ya quand
même ya quand même pas mal de 70 retweet
franchement si on arrive à 500 où il
retrouve peut-être qu'il peut se passer
quelque chose mais en écho à soixante
dix mes cinq sens je pense qu'on n'y
arrivera pas un truc dur c'est velud
ouais mais veut lui c'est moi je le dis
parce qu'il pensait le dit souvent
donc je dis naturellement ses voeux lui
j'aime bien ben tu vas 70e twitter on
réussira pas à monter mais à monter
beaucoup plus haut non ça va pas faire
assez toute façon même à 500 j'y croyais
pas trop mais mais bon on est peut-être
un pour les jeunes deux sangles daime
même je vais peut-être 100 à 500 milles
mais vrai que les anglais retweets ce
que je m'étais dit si ça reste que
franco-français de façon ça et ça ira
pas freeks à y faire avec ça les
américains très énervé et de partout
dans le monde que les gens veuillent
voir maxime de partout est vrai que ça
commence à restructurer mais ça me va
partout et sam avec le code avec le
conteur chaise comme officiel il va par
tweet et ses salles avantage d'avoir une
petite marque qui sont
faites fi est pas content c'est pas
grave non plus des gars de la fédé russe
pour la peine je les connais ils me
connaissent par le président de la fédé
russe fils at home je le connais pas
personnellement par contre le mec qui
s'en occupe
qui s'occupe de la fédé russe en réalité
je le connais j'ai déjà été dans son jab
eu des cognacs avec dans les hs 64 au
journal 64 km et rédacteur en chef de 64
donc est le plus gros journal russe
d'échec et je me suis déjà retrouvé avec
ce gars là à voir des cognacs et à
discuter des chèques à genre 23h dans
dans son bureau
donc tu as le gars quand il va voir mon
tweet fine connais-tu on se connaît il
fallait pas se rappeler qu'on ait vu des
cognacs ensemble donc voilà ça dépend où
notre vote qui se souvient de rien non
mais sinon c'était c'était gentil et y
avait rien de non mais tu as a dû finir
à 1h du mat c'était c'était très
cordiale cette petite discussion
c'était une discussion d'échecs avec des
jupes il y avait des journalistes avait
un mec qui est pas mal hein un grand
match géorgien qui joue bien qui
buvaient des coûts avec nous aussi donc
c'était non c'était cordiale et puis
j'allais souvent à la fédé russe et donc
c'est un gars que j'ai dû voir peut-être
30 fois dans ma vie de tous aux lilas
remarquer quand même que que je traînais
pas quoi comme d'agfa vos commentaires
ni leur train de se terminer et meyer
mathieu était écoeuré yayi s'est pris 5
heures les ai pris le plafond est ou non
moi pas une fois que franchement 12h jeu
max défini mois passé les départage ont
déjà avalé au blitz en fin de partie de
25 minutes un mini même le grand thiès
soir ben oui pardon de magnus ce n'était
pas très long oui oui c'est à partir
rapide alors que toutes les autres
parties ça fait 4 heures minimum mais du
coup c'est très bon signe quand je
commente quoi c'est qu'on s'ennuie pas
c'est fini vite ça gagne sa fille nul
mais ça fait nul ça traîne pas c'est une
heure de jeu bon du coup fab faisons les
sachets ben c'est toi qui vois là on est
on est éliminé les mecs on a encore un
petit espoir et on se retrouve
très bientôt pour championnat du monde
de billes c'est rapide mais recettes des
chaînes youtube aussi